I figured I'd do a little bit of a
stream today.
we're probably going to mess around with
Tiny for a bit and um and then watch the
Ilia podcast finally cuz
that's about what I got the energy to
do.
still have not fixed the vectorization
bug.
That will come with time.
Hey, Pepe Kinberg.
Let's start with Tiny Grado.
And then you can expect the streams to
uh to slow down a bit. I'd say next
week.
I don't know. I'm kind of at a point
where it's close to the holidays. I've
been working on this update for a couple
months straight. And uh I sort of just
want
all obligations to just disappear for a
few days to a week to two.
I will get some rest. Holy.
Just have a flock of several thousand
birds overhead.
Honestly, they remind me of like the
stuff we see out of our drone sims.
Perfect coordination. It's fun.
Let's go. And that is how you know for
sure I need a break. See birds think
about Sims. All right. Uh what we're
going to do.
Okay. So this was the tiny grab scan op
and I was linked
on the tiny grad discord.
Somebody linked to me. Here it is.
Variable to write a kernel.
See
9210.
This opened in full screen on my vert
monitor.
Okay. So you can add
variable start pause.
Huh.
This is kind of funky, right?
Welcome everybody.
And
oh, it's by name.
tiny variable.
Where's this imported?
Tiny gramp import tensor variable
Def variable
min val
max val
type.
Uh that doesn't make sense to me. Does
that make sense to anybody?
So
start pause
one max context minus one.
Wait, start pause is an int.
Oh,
Welcome Liberty
test. Tiny grab scan.
That's a little awkward though, isn't
it? Like
This is not exactly what we want. Here
is an example.
Check out test symbolic JIT for a few
examples with variable
So, what we're trying to do, right, is
just get this thing to output kernels
that work with variable hidden dim.
exported function has an extra argument
for each variable.
That's not bad.
So batch size
we can do hidden
horizon, right? We can do like this
cumulative sum.
so. So it's like what star
or all
star star uh
horizon
Okay.
Like did like am I just stupid here or
do like is there is this not weird?
Right. Like this is not the way I would
expect to bind
like to produce a variable kernel at
all.
Um, how would I expect to do it? I'd
expect to just like I don't know specify
the dimension
like tag the input variable dimension or
something. I guess this is supposed to
be more general cuz it's like it's over
whatever variable.
Okay.
Oh, well, hang on. I did something
stupid there.
Then do you pass it? Hang on. Do pass
B I
You do use it as an index.
So hang on. So this is going to be
all failed to be a single number.
Lovely.
Okay. Eval failed to be a single number.
So, it is actually pretty much what I
said I would expect. It's not quite the
syntax I would want maybe, but it's
actually
the more I look at it, the more this
does make sense. So, you're pretty much
you're just going to replace
index variables with this. Now, uh I
don't like the fact that you have to
like slice with it. This is super weird
to me.
Like, yeah, I don't understand how this
makes any sense, but
just let's try it because I think tiny
doesn't break debug, right? Horizon
log poets.
okay look define var
hidden 128 and then it has right there
the constant arg
okay this actually makes sense to me
right this makes sense
log hx
train step. I'm fine. Let's see.
But does this have to get passed to the
jet? Hang on.
JF is
jitted function.
Oh, I think you have to pass
I think you do it this way, right?
You don't actually pass horizon and
hidden as args. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. This
is better actually.
So we just do
o slice.
Wait, this whole thing is getting
jitted, right?
Yeah. So if this whole thing is getting
jittered, then we do it outside of train
step.
So we do
we do like this then. All right.
All right. So then look at this.
This slicing it technically doesn't do
anything, but I think that this tells
tiny that these axes need to be generic
in the kernel.
takes two values before we're given.
Okay. Yeah, we don't need this.
Eval failed to be
a single number
of one.
Yeah, that's really obnoxious right
there.
Um, that's really obnoxious. Some of
their error messages
definitely use some improving.
Yeah. So, eval failed to speed log.
Yeah. So, now we have the actual shape.
I just typed in shape and this looks
like a mess, but it's because it's the
it's like a variable shape.
Any tiny grad people in the chat see
anything wrong?
Let's um I'll tweet this. Maybe we will
pull some of the tiny people.
I wonder if there is just something
screwy with the cumulative sum. Let me
make sure that this looks correct first.
So
they jit the function
and then they pass
they pass a slice
Yeah.
Tiny jet f
contiguous.realize not realize without
contiguous the pad is not captured in
jet.
Without contiguous the pad is not
captured.
Yeah. No, it's
It's the same thing.
So then why why can't we do this is my
question.
Eval failed to be a single number. Range
is false to true
Selfshape
not equal new shape
Well, that seems bad.
Hey, Fabian, welcome.
I could try this on a different op for
now, right? It's possible that this is
just screwy for this.
I have a sense of how this works. Now,
let's go try RMS form real quick
cuz I mean this is the one that we would
really want a kernel from it for
anyways, right? Like this is the op
that's so obnoxious.
Let's see if this does anything. So we
can just do
variable stem
like so.
And uh this just needs hidden size,
right?
Oh,
train step tiny model obs. So, can I
just do obs like No, this whole thing
gets jitted. Hang on. So, it's OBS
action.
What?
Uh,
Is this a fair opt to use in testing? I
think it is. Right.
Well, if the colonel's that slow, that
doesn't help me.
Try the uh the forward pass, maybe.
Well,
How would you jet? Wait, how would you
even get yourself a backward forward
kernel?
Right? Because let me like the thing I'm
trying to do with this is if I can get
tiny to generate me fused kernels,
right? for um specific operations or
sets of operations, then I can
essentially replace the PyTorch backend
for those groups of operations with a
single kernel call because I can just
grab the CUDA and I can load it into um
the Puffer C++.
What is Puffer Lib? PufferLib is the
fastest reinforcement learning library.
We got a ton of demos here and I stream
all of the dev.
Everything from fun little games to
drones to driving.
Got lots of stuff.
to be determined. I actually have not
seen any of his content. It's like not
the type of stuff I like I normally
don't watch
um tech podcast type content.
If you talk about neural MMO, you should
mention develop new strategies.
Oh yeah, that's part for the course in
RL.
Are you game dev? I am a researcher my
guy.
I build puffer liib. I do high
performance simulation.
I do core reinforcement learning
algorithm research.
Um
do hyper pram optim.
We do custom simulation. Like we do a
ton of stuff here,
all open source.
forward? So if I do like RMS forward,
right?
That's cool. Thank you.
Yeah, it's kind of a uh a unique thing,
if you will. I uh I finished my PhD a
little under two years ago now, and
I sort of just took all the research
that I worked on in an academic setting
and then went way heavier into
engineering here on the open source
stuff. And we now have like you can
literally train agents to play several
of these games or sims or fly drones or
whatever on your laptop in under a
minute. It's pretty crazy how fast stuff
is now. Like most of the simpler tasks
on here, you can train these at home in
under a minute.
And that was just not remotely a thing
that existed two years ago. Give me
another couple years and then, you know,
maybe some of the more complex ones will
be similarly solvable at home.
Oh yeah, I'll show the maybe you can see
this on the stream. I just got a fun
delivery.
Let me see if I can just Can I spin the
camera? Yeah, I can.
Oh, my mic's in the way. Can you guys
kind of see it?
Yeah.
[laughter]
You see that?
not break my setup in the process of
showing that
we got a a nice screen for here and it's
going to have all the experiments live
on it for the foreseeable future.
But currently I have neural MMO runs up
on it.
saw the gym pumps.
Gym pumps. I mean, we got a lot of stuff
in here.
I just did uh first bench set before
stream started.
another one shortly.
What UI you're going to put on it? Uh,
we're going to try W to be again.
And if that sucks, then I think we'll
just run Constellation on it.
Constellation's the new one that I've
been working on for uh for Puffer 4. But
like Constellation really is not
designed at the moment for real-time
experiment monitoring. And I like
something that I can kind of just watch
over time.
Twitter broadcast are broken again.
Seriously,
it shows me as live,
so it looks good from my end.
Bit slow. That's on them.
I can't do anything about that.
I have my usual setup here.
I'm trying to think what you would do
for uh
backward here, right?
Okay. So, we're going to do here. We're
going to save all this.
Hang on. We have there a couple
different things. Let's Let's not get
overzealous here, right? So, first of
all, we're going to make sure we have
this
Okay.
So now this one.
Welcome Peru.
I got stuck on um I got stuck on the
uh multi-threading implementation.
There's one last bug I can't figure out
how to fix.
It's actually kind of more complicated
than I expected it would be. Maybe I
should show you real quick
here.
So, Peru wrote the um original version
and then I I did a whole bunch of stuff
from there. But
I can't
making progress on native eval that will
work better.
up for native. Are is this still using
torch? It is. Okay.
the lib torch. Okay.
Down to four.
This is super C++.
Uh,
what is this?
Wait for signal to do work.
Add work.
Wait. All done.
Can't say I'm a fan of all the C++
complicated atomic index. See, wait.
Hang on.
Yeah, this is missing the key thing that
was making this complicated though,
Peru. So like let me show you what I was
working on cuz like the key thing that
was making this hard was not the atomic
in like there's this whole additional
thing I had to add um because of the GPU
synchronization
like this is the entire C thread step
function. It's not a lot right
um the thing that makes this difficult
is you actually have this additional
layer where you're synchronizing the
GPU.
So you have to wait for when the actions
that are on the GPU buffer are ready
because they've been transferred to CPU.
Then you have to add work and then you
also have to then wait until so this is
actually the step that I can't figure
out how to do well which is just
figuring out when they've completed a
block of work rather like because they
can do blocks out of order. So it needs
to have be completed the next block of
work. Um but then after that you have to
initiate mem copies for testing. These
are synchronous but these are going to
be asynchronous
and you basically need to say hey the
observations are ready on CPU here and
then the main thread has to check when
the obs that are on CPU are done being
transferred to GPU.
So like there are multiple layers to
this thing and um pretty much the key
performance improvement that is expected
here is going to come from buffering the
GPU transfers.
Coincidentally I mean this is in 40 I'm
pretty sure I the thing is I cannot
figure out what I've done wrong here
that uh this can be done out of order or
something. I have a test that says, you
know, if I run this twice, do I have the
exact same obs and stuff at every step
and I cannot get that test to pass.
So, I don't know what's wrong. Um, I'm
sure there's like some pretty basic
error in here and it's just kind of
getting to that time where I need a few
days off before my head's going to be
clear enough to do something this
complex cuz like there's a lot going on
in here. Um,
but yeah,
I also don't love that we have we still
have some form of busy waiting on this,
right? Like this thread is constantly
going. So I this ideally should not have
to busy wait or like to just busy loop
whatever
there. I think this is the only spot
where I have it at the moment, which is
okay.
Pretty new to RL. Do you think I should
jump into a project, take a full course?
Uh, my guide on X-Men.
All my best advice is here because this
is the question I get most often.
none of the RL courses I've seen are any
good.
So there's some material, some formal
material, but it ain't a course,
no busy waiting, and it's lock based,
right? But like the reason I have busy
waiting is not because of your original
design. The reason I have busy waiting
is because of the additional GPU
synchronization.
You see
like the only this here, this entire
thing is looping constantly.
So, this thread needs to be designed
better, I'd say.
Oh, the other thing that drives me nuts
here. So, I couldn't figure out how to
do this. Um, you have all the threads
like grabbing work. I need to know when
a block of work is completed, which
means I need to know what like what is
the minimum index any thread is
processing at any given time.
Use the old C code with the new lib
torch stuff. Lib torch should not be
part of this in any way though, man.
Like lib torch should not have anything
to do with this. Why?
Like if this is correctly designed, this
should be completely separate from it.
Different segments in a BPT run proceed
on their own. No.
constant for the entire
different segments.
Uh let me actually let me think
that wouldn't make sense because you
need to process
you need all the elements in a batch
before you send it to a network.
You could technically do them out of
order and we used to do that. I don't
think it's a good idea though.
lib torch to transfer cuda simpler
design. Uh it doesn't though Peru let me
show you. You don't need to involve lib
torch at all here. Check this out.
These are raw CUDA Alex. So this is um
this here is in pinned memory and then
here you have the GPU buffers. So
there's no dependence on torch
whatsoever. Look, no torch here at all.
And then this is how I did it. Oops.
Check this out.
Boom. This is you just tell to use the
memory that you allocated from the ends.
So, this is actually completely
framework independent. Like, I could use
this exact same wreck with Tiny Grad or
Jax or whatever I want.
And there's zero PF cost to doing this
as well cuz you're just sharing memory
addresses.
Like honestly, the only thing like other
than the design quirks, I like
the thing that's driving me crazy is
just that I cannot figure out how to
make these tests work. So, how to make
like there's some async thing happening
in here that I don't understand.
Where is it?
Yeah, there's some async thing happening
in here that I don't understand that
something is out of order.
And then the other thing I'm I don't
love is that you have to have a separate
completion index per thread,
which means that your main thread has to
loop over all the atomics, one atomic
per thread to check if it's done.
How do you run forward LSTM pass? By the
way, final copy stuff after torch runs.
So
here I'll show you the puffer lib puffer
extensions.
I'll show you it's completely separate.
Okay. So in compile evaluate this is the
forward function.
So uh hang on.
Yeah. Vec receive. So this thing is
going to populate
this buffer
and then you grab your batch from here.
The policy runs on this batch. You
compute actions and you fill up your
buffers right here. Then this is here.
This is copying CPU uh this is copying
GPU actions to the GPU buffer.
And then vex send is going to async put
these actions back to CPU and tell the
environments to step.
So you can see like there is no
interaction whatsoever between the
policy and the end directly like that.
It's just this receive and this end.
That's it. And then like this device
synchronized is going to go away. All
these like synchronous transfers are
going to go away and everything gets to
be async.
But essentially, I have spent a couple
days fiddling with this and this is
confusing to me and this kind of
requires me to be on on point to figure
out
running torch for forward. Yes, exactly.
You don't have to use CUDA direct for me
copy though. You can use um torches
indexing actually
funny enough
because the thing about this
Okay, here hang on. So where's this?
I think that the way I have this at the
moment.
Yeah. So this is this is going to end up
being a synchronous GPUGGPU transfer.
And then when you call send, this will
initiate
a
I guess it will end up being a mem copy,
right? Yeah, it is a CUDA me uh mem
copy. uh this will end up being a
asynchronous
GPU to CPU transfer of actions and then
there's an internal mechanism that will
check it just like waits on the CUDA
stream for this operation and then when
this is done then it'll actually step
the M's and that all gets to be async.
Let me push this for you so you can see
it.
Actually, yeah, let me just let me push
you these couple tests so you can go
look at it if you want cuz I can't
figure it out. And if you can figure it
out, that'd be a great help.
So there's this DLL test and you
basically just scripts build you build
the vec and then you build DLL test and
then you can run test DLL
like this and then you'll get a mismatch
eventually.
That's the annoying bit with it.
Well, I think that this is going to be
moot anyways. This test here if the
speed is not up to par. So like
Yeah, because like the thing is
without this.
I'd really like to get kernels into
this.
They have to be variable.
They don't have to be variable kernels.
I guess
that is substantially less flexible
though.
I'm trying to think if we could do
forward.
really not a nice clean way to integrate
that at all, is there?
So basically what I was going to do is I
was going to figure out if I could get
tiny to like let's say we have a few
gate operations, right? Each one of
those is going to launch its own kernel.
It's really annoying. Um so we were
going to have tiny fuse some of those
which would reduce a lot of the overhead
associated with that.
But like first of all, tiny is
generating fixed size kernels.
So like I'd have to pre-ompile I guess
every kernel size and have a way to load
them.
And it's just tough because all the
stuff I'm trying to do, it's like
basically
nobody has docks for the stuff I want to
do, including torch.
Oh,
there's more stuff to work on. Let's
take a quick look at Vec. Anyways,
I don't know. I feel like I can take a
quick look at Vec and then um what it's
3. So if I start if I start the podcast
within the next half hour, I'll have
time to finish it before dinner.
So that's what we'll do after is we'll
watch the uh the Ilia podcast.
See how that goes.
Yeah. Yeah. And I like to be fair, I've
never actually heard's
interview style.
So
basically,
all of my opinions from it come from
interacting with viewers of the podcast
coming and saying dumb [ __ ] on my
stream. But that could very well just be
because he's got like a broad general
audience, right? I don't actually know
how he does in the interviews
themselves.
Give me a second. Let me go wipe my nose
and then let me get a bench set in.
We'll take a quick look at compile at um
multi thread and then we'll go from
there.
15 lbs lighter than the last time I did
that.
210 for 10.
All right. So, let me show what was
going on here.
Basically, I've got this script that
builds this endbinding file.
And then I've got also this script that
builds a test.
And
the test says
just make two environments that are both
multi-threaded and see if they do the
same thing.
hang on. I thought of one thing.
Okay. And good. So, there's nothing
random in the environment. I did
remember to comment out the RNG. So
because there is no randomness
in the environment
uh this test
this test should give us identical
results and that time it did
but there you go. So it can mismatch
right?
So the design of this thing
you have this manager thread
um you have a number of buffers as well.
Number of buffers is different from the
number of threads.
So you go through all the buffers
and this says if actions are ready on
the GPU, this is a flag that gets set as
soon as you start transferring actions
and this is the GPU stream that it's
being transferred on is synced. So if
it's ready on the GPU and
synchronization is done, then we
we add this block size to the end index.
We wake up the workers
And we store here.
And then to check if they're done, we go
through the completion indices for every
thread and we make sure that no thread
is working on uh a piece of data that we
still need.
So basically the minimum index has to be
start index plus block size. That's what
it's got to be.
If any thread is working on something
that is earlier than this index, it's
not done yet.
This says we can mark OBS ready on CPU,
which we do here. Technically, they're
already ready on GPU as well.
That is fine.
Hello, Jess. We looked at one quick
thing with Tiny and got stuck and now
I'm looking at VC and then uh probably
in about 20 minutes I'm going to go
watch the Ilia podcast on stream since I
said I would and I'm tired and I've been
putting it off and it's a good thing to
do. like it's a good thing to do when I
don't have too too much left in the
tank, which I've been saying for a week
now, and I'm going to keep saying it
until I take a week off,
Yeah, it is. It's kind of annoying as
well because like when I get burnt out,
it I don't even have anything that I
want to go do, right? It's not like, oh,
I want to take some time off to go do
this or that. Like I literally don't
even have anything else that I want to
do, but I can't really do this. Like
this is literally if I were active and,
you know, had the energy, this would be
the most interesting thing I could be
doing. But uh
what are you gonna do?
Maybe I'll go do a bunch of flexibility
training or something. see if I can uh
make some advancements on I've been
working on that for the past couple of
months.
Okay. What the heck did I just do wrong
in this? You say thread wake up
walk around nature rather than a run
around it.
I could totally just do that.
No, probably if I just forced myself to
like No, screw it. I'm going to go for a
4 hour walk. That would probably help a
bunch.
completed end.
I think this is fine, right? We say hey
threads wake up
while the completed index which is the
completed index of this thread is less
than the end.
You load the index right this is the
last index that's completed.
And if you load this index it means you
don't have any work left that you're
doing. So this is how far you've
completed.
Yeah I hear you Jess.
While completed is less than end, you
get the work index and you add the block
size.
Block start.
Wait, block start.
Huh?
Atomic fetch add.
Yeah. Okay. Okay, so you grab the work
index and then you add the block size.
So this is before you add it.
If it's greater than or equal to the
end,
then we have overounted. So we undo this
operation.
Oh. Oh. Oh, hang on. Hang on. What
happens?
What happens if you fetch a block of
work here?
Right? And then the end gets
incremented. So the other threads wake
up
They would start completing work that is
too far ahead. Right?
But then what happens?
I'm trying to think if it's possible
that like with some weird async stuff
this allows you to skip work
new heavy ball because it wants to
compile.
Yeah, we are going to do that. Man, I
told you I I reimplemented the heavy
ball muon
and it works like it works really well.
We already have it running neural MMO.
Neural MMO is
N. It's only at like four and a half
perf on the new run though. The new run
I was testing with I was testing
different gamma and lambdas.
It did something really weird though.
This is double buffering. Yes, this is
double buffered.
Hang on, let me see. So, if we do maybe
I'll try to draw it.
let's do like end
equals
work
So this is done here, right? So like
let's say we're done with block one
and then this is going to be T0.
So in thread zero
we get the block start.
The block start is going to be
248.
And then some other dude wakes up
and does.
Let's see the completed index.
Say we have completed
this 208.
Then some other dude is going to come in
and take this block.
Trying to think if you can get something
like this happening.
completed index. So completed index less
than end.
Multi-threading is actually very very
complicated to think about. Like it's
actually kind of funny how I was like ah
it's like 30 lines of code but this is
actually very very difficult for me to
think about
like I'm used to thinking about parallel
stuff all the time but like concurrent
stuff like this is actually very
difficult for me to like actually kind
of breaks my brain
cuz like the thing is you're used to
code being executed in order except
where specified otherwise and then this
flips it where everything is out of
order except at specific synchronization
points.
And yeah, sure, technically CUDA is like
that as well, but not for practical
purposes.
Like you don't end up with the same type
of race uh race conditions in that
versus in this at all.
Not often.
I think as soon as you count past the
end, you're screwed, right?
Because somebody else goes and grabs
that block of work.
I'd like to just have a simpler account,
like a simpler model. There's got to be
a simpler way to do this. No.
Ultimately, all I'm trying to do is
tell when a block of work is completed.
Let me try with a Let me try with like a
very specific. Let me just see if there
is an existing thing.
This model sucks though, but we'll try
it.
Barrier per block.
The most dog [ __ ] code you've ever seen.
a barrier. Wait, is it barrier? Wait,
did this barrier per block counter?
What the hell is this?
For each block,
falling out. Oh yeah, this Grock is a
stupid model. I don't know what the hell
they did to it, but it's literally worse
than uh the whatever they had before.
It's like faster time to token, but the
model's just stupid. You think Puffer
Lib could still significantly speed up
RL workflows if my environment requires
solving a linear system of equations at
each step taking around.5 seconds? Uh,
no. Why are you doing that?
No, you do. You do not do RL at 0.5
steps per second.
There are no libraries that will help
you with that. That is simply just not a
fun place to be in.
If it's not if it's like if there's any
way to cash stuff or something and speed
that up like do that first because
otherwise it's just intractable.
Golang does it. All right, Jess, if you
know go like how would you do this? This
should be a very standard problem,
right?
simplest way possible to just like
I mean literally it's it is just you
have a bunch of tasks and you need to
know when like a specific block of them
are completed
10 to 100 SPS
many asynchronous environments as
possible
get around 10 to 100 SPS
can you cash stuff.
Like, do you really have to solve a
different system of linear equations?
latch count. Okay, hang on. What's this?
Latch countdown.
You guys, that's super easy, isn't it?
Like I don't have it designed exactly
for this, but
caching is not easy.
It need to run an electrical simulation
each step.
Are you only changing the simulation a
little bit?
Do you need to full solve it or can you
do like
pretty much the key to like applying RL
to just about everything is just
figuring out how to do a fast
approximate sim.
This is a pretty good pattern though,
right? Like this type of a thing.
And this is actually quite easy
because
it's literally just a modulo to know
which block this is in.
Oh, and I'm pretty sure we're guaranteed
that you can never It's a circular
buffer, but we're guaranteed you can
never eat the tail of the buffer.
I think this works.
I don't have time to implement this now.
Um cuz this is going to be C obviously
and have to restructure a couple things.
But I think this is a way better um a
way better way to solve it. This is
actually way quicker to check. So, this
will this will be fast as well.
What the heck? Huh? What did I just do?
I didn't even know you could do that.
All right. I think we're going to do the
uh the Ilia podcast next. I'm happy with
that bit of progress. Um, I will
definitely be able to implement that.
Clean the parameters of the circuit and
rerun the simulation for new params.
Thought about training like a circuit
model and then jacks everything.
Uh, I don't suggest trying to replace
your circuit with like a learn sim. That
I definitely don't suggest.
Is RL and LM and RL and like robotic sim
the same principle? Nope. Not remotely
close. RL and LM is like stupid baby
mode.
And the fact that you see like results
competitive with RL from really dumb
methods is because they're using the
dumbest possible version of RL.
To be fair, some of the robotic stuff is
a bit bloated, but at least you can
learn proper value functions and such.
Robotics also suffers from just Sims
being slow.
Uh, let me go find Let me go find that
podcast.
like this
reaction content.
Look, people asked for it. Okay,
resize. I'm going to make the chat a
little smaller for this.
Get a fake mustache and make this take
10 hours.
All right, [sighs]
let me get my bench set in. I'm a J.
[laughter]
Hey, he actually has some decent stuff.
All right, like of of the actual um tech
streamers, he actually has some decent
stuff. All right. Uh
yeah, let me go get my set in. I'm use a
restroom real quick. We'll watch this
and that'll be today.
And eventually we'll get some real work.
That's
Buffer Jenn is a collab. I'd actually be
down for that, honestly.
Like, believe it or not, I found some of
his content before I got on this crazy
low-level engineering kick, and I
actually got some useful information
from his stuff that uh that helped me
when I was learning some more things.
Batching approach.
Is that Peru?
Yo, Peru. I'm pretty sure I'm pretty
sure we just figured it out.
I think it's going to be this. I don't
know why I didn't think of this before,
but I think of this. It's this type of a
thing where we have one uh counter per
buffer and it just counts down. I think
this works.
When the batch completes, add work to
process it in another thread.
Okay, we'll take a look at that. I'm
going to do this thing now, though.
So, let me [clears throat] I'm not going
to answer random questions during this
um that aren't about this thing.
I'll probably upload this to YouTube as
well.
So, let me give you some context for
this. Okay.
Context bit number one. This is not the
type of content I normally watch. I
don't usually watch like ideas in AI.
Heck, I don't even watch like AI stuff
in Hollywood or anything. Um, obviously
this isn't that, but I'm not really a
fan of like, you know, big like big
thoughts in the field or whatever. I
really prefer like detailed technical
content on precisely like this is what
we're doing in research. Clearly, this
is what's going to work next. We know
this from X, Y, and Z, right? Much more
precise things rather than big picture.
Everybody's wrong half the time, but
like maybe this guy's wrong a little
less than half the time, right?
So, that's context number one. Um,
context number two, I did spend some
time at OpenAI. I interned there for
about six months uh as an undergrad at
Stanford
and then after that I followed Philip
who I worked with there to MIT because
he started a professorship and he became
my adviser there. Um
I knew Ilia from there mostly via
conversations I had over lunch. Um he is
one of the top three probably
smartest people I've met. Uh he has
I mean just the amount of stuff that
he's done and the way that he saw the
field at that time. Also you know having
been at those places I can say that open
AI in 2018 like you go from there to MIT
or Stanford and it literally looks like
Dumb and Dumber. um the people that were
at OpenAI just blew everybody else out
of the water. It wasn't even close. So
yeah, that's pretty much it is I know
him from having know he led the
technical team that blew everybody else
out of the water in the era that
produced what is in my opinion the
greatest RL results ever. In addition to
obviously GPT, the stuff that Alec was
working on there. Um,
tons and tons of stuff. So, I have a ton
of respect for Ilia. Uh, people like
comment weird stuff at me about effiges
and [ __ ] I I don't know what the [ __ ]
any of that is. Um, so I'm going to go
just off of this. I'm going to see if I
the same as I remember or whatnot. I've
never heard Cash talk. Um, the only
negative impressions I have of him are
from viewers coming and commenting
stupid [ __ ] about, you know, the latest
podcast episode in my stream. But that
could very well be because it's just a
very general audience. I don't know.
We're going to see and I'll tell you
what I think about it.
Cuz you haven't made any sci-fi yet.
We can hear you, but not Ilia. I am
dumb. Let me fix that.
All right. All right. All right. Here.
Uh, the initial
All right.
>> You know,
>> so the reason that AI doesn't feel
sci-fi is nobody's done any cool sci-fi
[ __ ] yet.
>> Like,
>> it's crazy.
>> Let me know what all of this is real.
>> All right. Here we go.
>> Don't you think so?
>> Meaning,
>> like all this AI stuff and all this
area. Yeah. That it's happen like
>> isn't it straight out of science
fiction? Yeah. Another thing that's
crazy is like how normal the slow
takeoff feels.
>> The idea that we'd be investing 1% of
GDP in AI. Like I feel like it would
felt like a bigger deal, you know, where
right now it just feels like
>> you get used to things pretty fast.
Turns out Yeah. But also it's kind of
like it's abstract. Like what does it
mean? What it means that you see it in
the news.
>> Yeah.
>> That such and such company announced
such and such dollar amount,
>> right?
>> That's that's all you see,
It's not really felt in any other way so
far.
>> Yeah. Should we actually begin here? I
think this is an interesting discussion.
>> Sure.
>> I think your point about well from the
average person's point of view, nothing
is that different will continue being
true even into the singularity.
>> No.
That's dumb.
>> Okay. Interesting.
>> So the thing which I was referring to
not feeling different.
>> Not really better yet.
is okay so such and such company
announced some difficult to comprehend
dollar amount of investment
>> right
>> I don't think anyone knows what to do
with that
>> but I think that the impact of AI is
going to be felt
>> AI is going to be diffused through the
economy there are very strong economic
forces for this
>> and I think the impact is going to be
felt very strongly
>> when do you expect that impact I think
The models seem smarter than their
economic impact would imply.
>> No, the models are dumb as [ __ ]
>> This is one of the very confusing things
about the models right now. How to
reconcile
the fact that they are doing so well on
evals.
>> Yeah, they're over.
>> You look at the evals and you go, those
are pretty hard evals. Yeah,
>> they're doing so well,
but the economic impact seems to be
dramatically behind.
>> And it
>> it's just like the benchmaxing meme,
right? It's like you go see all model
solves, IMO, whatever, and then you give
it some basic ass programming problem
and it completely flops. Like when you
have that much money in place, there's a
huge amount of incentive to do well on
those evals and not that much incentive
to actually make sure it's generally
good cuz like at least the thing in the
news and the thing with investments and
all this is eval
like you'll believe it when the models
are actually useful broadly and are not
constantly being stupid. It's almost
like
it's it's very difficult to make sense
of how can the model on the one hand do
these amazing things and then on the
other hand
>> like repeat itself twice in some
situation in kind [clears throat] of a
>> an example would be let's say you use
vibe coding to do something and you go
to some place and then you get a bug
>> and then you tell the model can you
please fix the bug
>> and the model says oh my god you're so
right I have a bug let me go fix that
and it introduces a second bug.
>> Yeah. [clears throat]
>> And then you tell it you have you have
this new second bug and it tells you oh
my god how could have done it. You're so
right again
>> and brings back the first bug and you
can alternate between those.
>> Yeah.
>> And it's like how is that possible?
>> It's like I'm not sure but it does
>> cuz hyper I want to listen to Ilia. This
is the only person the only guest he
could have possibly gotten that would
have gotten me to watch this.
suggests that the
something strange
>> maybe Brockman but probably not
>> have two possible explanations. So here
this is the more kind of
>> maybe Radford
>> whimsical explanation is that maybe RL
training makes the models a little bit
too single-minded and narrowly focused a
little bit too
I don't know unaware
even though it also makes them aware
>> base models were also [ __ ]
>> and because of this they can't do basic
things but there is another explanation
which is
back when people were doing pre-training
the question of what data to train on
was answered because the that answer was
everything.
>> Everything. Yeah.
>> When you do pre-training, you need all
the data.
>> What about Alman? [ __ ] Now,
>> you don't have to think is it going to
be this data or that data.
>> Yeah.
>> But when people do RL training, they do
need to think. They say okay, we want to
have this kind of RL training for this
thing and that kind of RL training for
that thing. And from what I hear, all
the companies have teams that just
produce new RL environments and just add
it to the training mix. And the question
is what are those? There are so many
degrees of freedom. There is such a huge
variety of real environments you could
produce. And one of the
one thing you could do and I think
that's something that is done
inadvertently
is that people take inspiration from the
evals. You say, "Hey,
of our model to do release it. I want
the Evos to look great.
>> What would be our only bench to help on
this task, right?
>> I think that is something that happens
and I think it could explain a lot of
what's going on. If you combine this
with generalization of the models
actually being inadequate,
that has the potential to explain a lot
of what we are seeing. this disconnect
between eval performance and actual real
real world performance which is
something that we don't
>> today exactly even understand what
>> this is why I ignore all the new model
releases
>> I like this idea that the real reward
hacking is the human researchers who are
too focused
>> um I think there's two ways to
>> this is nothing new we've seen this in
RL for a decade like this is why I say
all the RL research is [ __ ] Like you
literally just go look at the posters,
you see the experiments you that they
make, you say, "Well, that can't
possibly be generalizable, you try it,
it isn't." Woe and behold. It's just
like, "Congratulations, we managed to
replicate the past decade of [ __ ]
research, but now with the scale of
billions of dollars." Understand or to
try to think about what what you have
just pointed out. One is look, if it's
the case that simply by becoming
superhuman at a coding competition, a
model will not automatically become more
tasteful
and exercise better judgment.
>> Okay, taste is such a [ __ ] stupid
concept, man. The models are just bad.
Like unequivocally bad.
It's like, oh, there's like this learned
subjective thing. Yeah, sure, within
certain bounds. That's not what the
models are. they're just bad
>> about how to improve your codebase.
Well, then you should expand the suite
of environments such that you're not
just testing it on having the best
performance in coding competition. It
should also be able to make the best
kind of application for X thing or Y
thing or Z thing. And another maybe this
is what you're hinting at is to say why
should it be the case in the first place
that becoming super human at coding
competitions doesn't make you a more
tasteful programmer. more generally
maybe the thing to do is not to keep
stacking up the amount of environments
and the diversity of environments to
figure out an approach with let you
learn from one environment and improve
your performance on something else.
>> So I have I have an analogy which might
be helpful. So even the case let's take
the case of competitive programming
since you mentioned that and suppose you
have two students
one of them work decided they want to be
the best competitive programmer so they
will practice
>> for that domain
>> they will solve all the problems
memorize all the proof techniques and be
very very
>> you know
be very skilled at quickly and correctly
implementing all the algorithms and by
doing by doing so they became
the best one of the best. Student number
two thought, oh, competitive programming
is cool. Maybe they practiced for a 100
hours,
>> much much less, and they also did really
well. Which one do you think is going to
do better in their career later on?
>> The second,
>> right? And I think that's basically
what's going on. The models are much
more like the first student, but even
more because then we say, okay,
>> is that what it is?
I guess in my mind like because I'm so
used to RL
LMS are not trained on any data. Like
the LLM people have billions of dollars
in zero data. I train on more data on
one server than OpenAI uses for all of
pre-training.
I don't think it's like oh they just
need too much data.
Let's let's okay let's see.
>> So the model should be good with
competitive programming. So let's get
every single competitive programming
problem ever. And then let's do some
data augmentation. So we have even more
competitive programming problems.
>> Yes.
>> And we train on that. And so now you got
this great competitive programmer. And
with this analogy I think it's more
intuitive. I think it's more intuitive
with this analogy that Yeah. Okay. So if
it's so well trained, okay, it's like
all the different algorithms.
>> Oh, okay. So yes, I can see why that's a
problem with language models, I guess.
Well, how much data is that? Does
anybody know?
Like how much does it cost to RL
fine-tune on every
every competitive programming problem
ever? cuz you know from the amount of
data I'm used to that's just no data. So
like my mind just immediately goes oh
that's free but maybe that is millions
or tens of millions of dollars for each
new thing you want to solve. Like the
approach I have with Puffer is
fundamentally different because we do
basically do the equivalent of let's
train on every competitive programming
problem ever. It's just that we do it
instantly on one machine because
everything is so fast, right? And we
scale data. we don't scale model size or
compute anywhere near as hard
>> then all the different proof techniques
are like right it at its fingertips
and it's more intuitive that with this
level of preparation it not would not
necessarily generalize to other things
>> but then what is the um analogy for what
the second student is doing before
>> tokens
of finetuning
>> I think it's like
they have it I think it's the it factor
>> yeah Right. And like I know like when I
was in undergrad, I remember there was
there was a student like this that
studied with me. So I I know it exists.
>> Yeah. I think it's interesting to
distinguish it from whatever
pre-training does. So one way to
understand what you just said about we
don't have to choose the data in
pre-training is to say actually it's not
dissimilar to the 10,000 hours of
practice. It's just that you get that
10,000 hours of practice for free
because it's already somewhere in the
pre-training distribution. But it's like
maybe you're suggesting actually there's
actually not that much generalization
for pre-training. There's just so much
data in pre-training. Everybody's like
it's not necessarily generalizing better
than RL.
>> Like the main the main strength of
pre-training is that there is a
>> pre-training generalizing better than
RL. Well,
>> that's hard to quantify. so much of it
>> anyless
>> and B you don't have to think hard about
what data to put into pre-training
>> whatever
>> and it's a very kind of natural data
>> well not really like it's language data
right and this is actually one of the
big limitations right which is why I say
hey LM will never solve this problem or
that like why the hell would you ever
plug a a language model into drone
control right it's like some fiddly
unintuitive low-level optimization
problem
you're not going just put raw RAM states
from everything into a language model,
right? You're not going to just bite
model everything.
>> And it does include in it a lot of what
people do.
>> Anthropic is the worst when it comes to
hype. Anthropic when Anthropic split off
from OpenAI originally, it was just all
the crazy people leaving.
>> Yeah.
people's thoughts and a lot of the
features of you know it's like the whole
world as projected by people onto text.
>> Yeah. and pre-training tries to capture
>> the whole world.
there are very very substantial gaps in
that uh there is important data that is
not projected into text and that is one
of the key things I'm doing with RL
right like RL is good for fiddly
unintuitive optimization problem the
stuff I'm doing will never be good on
its own for just processing text in the
way a language model is right maybe some
of the stuff I come up with ends up
informing algorithms over there but the
approach I'm taking will never directly
one to one but similarly I don't see how
LM's ever onetoone this other thing so I
do think that there is a gap
>> that using a huge amount of data
it's it's very the pre-training is very
difficult to reason about because it's
so hard to understand the manner in
which
>> oh son of liberty it's like it's way
worse than that so when I was doing
neural MMO I had one of the early guys
uh who joined Enthropic super early
talked to me and he said actually we are
afraid of your like little single PhD
1GPU RL project like your neural MMO
stuff is super scary. Uh, also, you
know, if you wanted to like consider
joining Enthropic early, you should know
that like all the equity is matched is
locked up in donation matching cuz, you
know, we're not going to do this to get
rich. And the guy telling me this was
somebody who'd retired off of trading in
his 20s.
[laughter]
It was like just crazy out of touch
people.
>> The model relies on pre-training data.
And whenever the model makes a mistake,
>> yeah, LMS will be a huge shame
>> because something by chance is not as
supported by the pre-training data, you
know, and pre support by pre-training is
maybe a loose term.
>> I I don't know if I can add anything
more useful on this, but
I don't think there is a human analog to
pre-training.
>> Here's analogies that people have
proposed.
>> I don't think there is a human analog to
pre-training.
Yeah, evolution is the one that I use,
but it's not remotely a onetoone at all.
Like, it's a really, really bad analogy.
It's better than no analogy, but it's a
really bad one.
>> What the human analogy to pre-turning
is, and I'm curious to get your thoughts
on why they're potentially wrong. One is
>> not answering off-topic questions during
this liberty
>> is to think about the first 18 or 15 or
13 years of a person's life when they
aren't necessarily economically
productive but they are doing something
that is making them understand the world
better and so forth. And the other is to
think about evolution as doing some kind
of search for three billion years which
then results in a human lifetime
instance and then I'm curious if you
think either of these are actually
analogous to pre-training or how how
would you think about at least what
lifetime human learning is like if not
pre-training.
>> I think there are some similarities
between both of these two pre-training
and pre-training tries to play the role
of both of these
>> but I think there are some big
differences as well.
The amount of pre-training data is
very very staggering.
>> Yes.
And somehow a human being after even 15
years with a tiny fraction of that
pre-training data they know much less.
>> Yeah.
>> But whatever they do know they know much
more deeply somehow. And the mistakes
like
>> Yeah. See IA just says what I say but
way better.
>> Make mistakes that make.
>> Yeah.
>> There is another thing you might say.
Could it be something like evolution?
And the answer is maybe. But in this
case I think evolution might actually
have an edge. Like there is this I
remember
reading about this case where some you
know that one thing that neuroscientists
do or rather one way in which
neuroscientists can learn about the
brain is by studying people with brain
damage to different parts of the brain
>> and and so and some people have the most
strange symptoms you could imagine. It's
actually really really interesting and
there was one case that comes to mind
that's relevant.
I read about this person who had some
kind of brain damage that took out I
think a stroke or an accident that took
out his emotional
processing. So he stopped feeling any
emotion
and as a result of that you know he
still remained very articulate and he
could solve little puzzles and on tests
he seemed to be just fine but he felt no
emotion. He didn't feel sad. He didn't
feel anger. He didn't feel animated and
he became somehow extremely bad at
making any decisions at all. It would
take him hours to decide on which socks
to wear and he would make very bad
financial decisions.
And that's very
does what what does it say about
the role of our built-in emotions
in making us like a viable agent
essentially? And I guess to connect to
your question about pre-training
>> that seems a powerful
>> maybe pre like maybe if you are good
enough at like getting everything out of
pre-training you can get you you could
get that as well but that's the kind of
thing which seems
well it may or may not be possible
>> pre-training is not enough I agree
>> from pre-train
>> what is
that clearly not just directly motion it
seems like
>> yeah but like Ilia knows that liberty
dude Come on.
>> Almost value function like thing which
is giving telling you which decision to
be like what the end reward for any
decision should be and you think that
doesn't sort of implicitly come from
>> I think doesn't have an interaction.
>> It's not one it's not 100% obvious.
>> Yeah. But what is that like what how do
you think about emotions and what is the
ML analogy for emotions?
>> It should be some kind of a value
function thing.
>> Yeah. But I don't think there is a great
ML analogy because right now value
functions don't play a very prominent
role in uh the things people do.
>> It might be worth defining for the
audience what a value function is if you
want to do that
>> the thing you can't learn in LMS which
is why your RL doesn't work
>> right. So
so when people do reinforcement learning
the way reinforcement learning is done
right now how do they do how do people
train those agents? So you have your
neural net and you give it a problem and
then you tell the model go solve it and
the model takes maybe thousands hundreds
of thousands of actions
or thoughts or something and then it
produces a solution. The solution is
created and then the score
is used to provide a training signal for
every single action
in your trajectory.
So that means that if you are doing
something that goes for a long time, if
you're training a task that takes a long
time to solve, you will do no learning
at all until you solve until you came up
with a proposed solution. That's how
reinforcement learning is done naively.
That's how 01 R1 ostensibly are done.
The value function says something like
okay look maybe I could sometimes not
always could tell you if you're doing
well or badly the notion of a value
function is more useful in some domains
than others. So for example, when you
play chess,
>> it's critical
>> and you lose a piece like I messed up
>> like most of what we have. To be fair,
there are some that don't need
>> the whole game to know that what I just
did was bad and therefore whatever um
>> RL doesn't work without value functions,
which is why LM RL is such a mean.
>> The value function lets you short
circuit the weight until the very end.
Like let's suppose that you started to
pursue some kind of um okay let's
suppose that you are doing some kind of
a math thing or a programming thing
>> and you're trying to explore direction
>> and after let's say after a thousand uh
steps of thinking you concluded that
this direction is unpromising.
As soon as you conclude this you could
already get a reward signal a thousand
time steps previously when you decided
to pursue down this path. you say oh
next time I shouldn't pursue this path
in a similar situation long before you
actually came up with a proposed
solution
>> this was in the deepcar one paper is
that the
space of trajectory so wide
>> dude it's in like classic
from
>> an intermediate trajectory
>> realistically much more than a dec and
also given that you know in coding for
example you'll have the wrong idea then
you'll go back then you'll change
something
>> this Sounds like such lack of faith in
deep learning.
>> Like I mean sure it might be difficult
but
>> nothing deep learning can't do.
>> Yeah.
>> So
>> my expectation is that
like value functions should be useful
and
>> then I fully I fully expect that they
will be used in the future if not
already. What was I alluding to with the
person whose emotional center got um
damaged is more that
maybe what it suggests is that the value
function eccentric. This is because I
had the chance to talk to him at many
lunches when I was an intern at OpenAI
and he was one of the most brilliant
people I've ever met. I don't say that
lightly. Like I would not say the same
thing about Sam Olman or even some of
the other people at OpenAI though many
of them were very very good him Greg
Brockman Alec Radford on algorithm side
at the very least Schulman we're very
smart people
>> of humans is modulated by emotions in
some important way that's hardcoded by
evolution
and maybe that is important for people
to
be effective in the world
>> that that's the thing I was actually and
asking you there's something really
interesting about emotions as a value
function which is that it's impressive
that they have this much utility while
still being rather
um simple to understand.
So I have two responses. I do agree that
compared to
the kind of things that we learn and the
things we talking about the kind of ads
we talking about emotions are relatively
simple.
They might even be so simple that maybe
you could map them out in a human
understandable way. I think it would be
cool to do.
In terms of utility though, I think
there is a thing where you know there is
this complexity robustness trade-off
where complex things can be very useful
but simple things are very useful in
very broad range of situations. And so I
think what what one way to interpret
what we are seeing is that we've got
these emotions that essentially evolved
mostly mostly from our mammal ancestors
and then fine-tuned a little bit while
we were homminides just a bit. We do
have like a decent amount of social
emotions though which mammals may lack
but they're not very sophisticated
and because they're not sophisticated
they serve us so well in this very
different world compared to the one that
we've been living in. Actually they they
also make mistakes. For example, our
emotions well I don't know does hunger
count as an emotion?
It's debatable but I think for example
our intuitive feeling of hunger
is not succeeding in guiding us
correctly in this world with an
abundance of food.
>> Yeah, people have been talking about
scaling data.
Okay, I actually kind of like this is a
weird tangent, but like
>> is there a more general way to think
about scaling? What are the other
scaling axes?
>> So
the thing So so here here is a
perspective here's a perspective I think
might be might be true.
>> So
>> it actually does kind of make sense if
you're thinking about RL though
>> is that people would just think of stuff
and try to
get interesting results.
That's still how it works in the past.
>> Then
the scaling arrived, right? Scaling logs
GPT3.
And suddenly everyone realized we should
scale.
And it's just an example
>> of how language affects thought.
>> Scaling is what? Just one word, but it's
such a powerful word because it informs
people what to do. They say okay let's
let's try to scale things
>> the scale the wrong
>> say okay so what are we scaling
>> and pre-training was the thing to scale
it was a particular scaling recipe
>> yes
>> the big breakthrough of pre-training is
the realization that this recipe is good
>> so you say hey if you
>> mix some compute with some data into a
neural net of a certain size you will
get results and you will know that it
will be better if you just scale the
recipe up and this is also great
companies love this because it gives you
a very uh lowrisk way of investing
>> your resources
>> right it's much harder to invest your
resources in research
>> compare that you know if you research
you need to have like go forth research
and come up with something
>> just like they're basically a bunch of
super simple heruristics that you can
use in pretty much any new environment
And it's very difficult to get agents to
learn anything that looks like those
heristics.
Um
like
yeah,
so it's kind of a weird tangent to
addressed in a way that makes more sense
than because normally it's like a
totally stupid tangent. This one's like
okay that's kind of sure
>> versus
>> he's thinking about get more compute you
know you'll get something from
pre-training
and indeed you know it looks like I
based on various um
um things people say on some people say
on Twitter maybe it appears that Gemini
have found a way to get more out of
pre-training at some point though
pre-training will run out of data the
data is very clearly finite
>> and so then okay what do you do next
>> either you do some kind of a souped up
pre-training different recipe from the
one we've done before or you're doing RL
or maybe something else but now that
comput is big computer is now very big
in some sense we are back to the age of
research so maybe here's another way to
put it up until 2020 from 20 from 20
2012 to 2020 it was the age of
>> yes
>> now from 2020 to 2025 it was the age of
scaling
>> I got to say arrow bars to those years
because people say this is amazing you
got to scale more. Keep scaling the one
word scaling. But now the scale is so
big. Like is is it is the belief really
that oh it's so big but if you had 100x
more everything would be so different.
Like it would be different for sure.
>> Yeah.
>> But like is the belief that if you just
100x the scale everything would be
transformed.
I don't think that's true.
>> So it's back to the age of research
again just with computers.
>> That's a very interesting way to put it.
research is really inefficient with big
computers though.
>> What are we scaling and what what is
what would it mean to have a recipe
because
>> big open source project
>> a very clean
>> got de relationship that almost looks
like a law of physics which existed in
pre-training was a power
>> we do tiny models with a ton of data
>> computer parameters and more data than
they have. what is the kind of
relationship we should be seeking and
how how should we think about what this
new recipe might look like?
>> So, we've we've already witnessed a
transition from
one type of scaling to a different type
of scaling from pre-training to RL
>> scale. People are scaling RL now based
on
>> scale the number of stars on puffer. Go
star the puffer repo. I
>> spend more on RL than on pre-training at
this point. Because RL can actually
consume quite a bit of compute scale
long
>> rollouts.
>> Yes.
>> So it takes a lot of compute to produce
those rollouts and then you get
relatively small amount of learning
polar roll out. So you really
>> fun fact I literally on the monitor
behind me have 40,000 years worth of
gameplay RL experiments that I've been
running over time. Yeah, we have that's
like
uh I think that's like 20 pabytes
uh uncompressed.
Yeah, we got lots of data. So, we know
what to scale there.
>> You can spend you really can spend a lot
of compute and I would imagine
>> like I wouldn't at this at this it's
more like
>> I wouldn't even call it a scale scaling.
I would say hey like what are you doing
>> and is the thing you are doing the the
the the most productive thing you could
be doing.
>> Yeah.
>> Can you find a most more productive way
of using your compute? We've discussed
the value function business earlier
>> and maybe once people get good at value
functions they will be using their their
um resources more productively.
And if you find a whole other way of
training models, you could say is this
scaling or is it just using your
resources, I think it becomes a little
bit ambiguous in a sense that when
people were in the age of research back
then, it was like people say, hey, let's
try this and this and this. Let's try
that and that. Oh, look, something
interesting is happening. And I think
there will be a return to that.
>> So, if we're back in the era of
research, stepping back, what is the
part of the recipe that we need to think
most about? When you say value function,
people are already trying the current
recipe, but then having LLM as a judge
and so forth. You can say that's a value
function, but it sounds like you have a
really function. Do we need to go back
to
>> such a bad rethink
>> pre-training at all and not just add
more steps to the end of that process?
>> Yeah. So the the the discussion about
value function, I think it was
interesting. I want to like emphasize
that I think the value function is
something like
it's going to make RL more efficient
and I think that makes a difference.
>> But I think that anything you can do
with a value function you can do without
just more slowly.
>> Mhm. Way more slowly.
>> The thing which I think is the most
fundamental is that these models somehow
just generalize dramatically worse than
people.
>> Yes.
>> And it's super obvious.
That's that seems like a very
fundamental thing.
>> Okay, so this is the crux of
generalization and there's two
sub questions.
There's one which is about sample
efficiency which is why should it take
so much more data for these models to
learn than humans. There's a second
about even separate from the opposite is
a question of
>> why is it so hard to teach the thing we
want to a model than to a human which is
to say
>> for to a human we don't necessarily need
a verifiable reward to be able to
probably mentoring a bunch of
researchers right now and you're you
know talking with them you're showing
them your code and you're showing them
how you think and from that they're
picking up your way of thinking and how
they should do research. You don't have
to set like a verifiable reward for them
that's like okay this is the next part
of the curriculum and now this is the
next part of your curriculum and oh it
was training was unstable and we gota
there's not this schleppy bespoke
process.
>> So perhaps these two issues are actually
related in some way but I'd be curious
to
>> explore this this second thing which
feels more like continual learning and
this first thing which feels just like
um sample efficiency.
>> Yeah. So you know you could actually
wonder one one possible explanation for
the human sample efficiency that needs
to be considered is evolution.
>> Yeah that's what I always say humans are
not popular
>> has given us a small amount of the mo
the most useful information possible
and for things like vision
hearing and locomotion
I think there's a pretty strong case
that evolution actually has given us a
lot
So for example, human dexterity far
exceeds I mean robots can become
dexterous too if you subject them to
like a huge amount of training and
simulation.
>> Super human
>> to train a robot in the real world to
quickly like pick up a new skill like a
person does seems very out of reach. And
here you could say, oh yeah, like
locomotion all our ancestors needed
great locomotion squirrels like so
locomotion maybe like we've got like
some unbelievable prior.
>> You could make the same case for vision
you know I I believe
>> Yan Lan made the point oh like um
children learn to drive after 16 hour
after 10 hours of practice which is true
but our vision is so good.
>> Yeah. At least for me, I mean, I
remember myself being five year old. My
I was I was very excited about cars back
then,
>> and I'm pretty sure my car recognition
was more than adequate for self-driving
already as a 5-year-old.
>> You don't get to see that much data as a
5-year-old. You spend most of your time
in your parents house,
>> so you have very low data diversity, but
you could say maybe that's evolution,
too.
>> But in language and math and coding,
probably not.
>> It still seems better than models. I
mean obviously models are better than
the average human at language and math
and coding but are they better at the
average human at learning?
>> Oh yeah. Oh yeah. Absolutely. What I
meant to say is that language, math and
coding and especially math and coding
suggests that whatever it is that makes
people
good at learning
is probably not so much a complicated
prior but something more some
fundamental thing.
>> Wait, I'm not sure I understood. Why
should that be the case? So consider a
skill
that people exhibit some kind of great
reliability or you know um
>> if the skill is one that was very useful
to our ancestors for many millions of
years, hundreds of millions of years,
you could say you could argue that maybe
humans are good at it because of
evolution because we have a prior
>> an evolutionary prior that's encoded in
some very nonobvious way.
>> Yeah.
>> That somehow makes us so good at it.
>> But if people exhibit great ability,
reliability, robustness, ability to
learn in a domain that really did not
exist until recently,
then this is more an indication that
people might have
just better machine learning period.
>> Kind of have to deconstruct the domain.
What that is? Is it a matter of
>> Yeah. What is the ML analogy for what?
There's a couple interesting things
about it. It takes fewer samples. It's
more unsupervised. You don't have to set
a ver like a child learning to drive a
car. Children are not learning to drive
a car. A teenager learning how to drive
a car is like not exactly getting
some pre-built verifiable reward.
it comes from their interaction with the
machine and the with the environment.
Um, and yet it takes much fewer samples.
It seems more unsupervised. It seems
more robust.
>> Much more robust. The robustness of
>> It's not Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
>> It's really
>> It's
like
you already have autonomous vehicles
better than the average driver. They
take way more data, but the ceiling is
way higher. Like even in a decade, we're
going to look back like, "Oh, wait. What
the hell? We have people driving cars."
Okay, maybe the bureaucracy will take
longer than that. But like,
yeah, you definitely can get way more
robustness out of models like non-
language models, RL models. Yeah. Way,
way, way more robustness than people
have, but it takes a ton of data. That's
the difference.
>> Staggering.
>> Yeah. So like okay
>> in the context of language models that's
true though
>> why are all these things happening at
once what is the ML analogy that would
that could be could realize something
like this
>> so so so um this is where you know one
of the things that you've been asking
about is how can you know the teenage
driver kind of self-correct and learn
from their experience without an
external teacher
>> and the answer is well they have their
value function
>> right they have a general sense which is
also by the way extremely robust in
people like
>> whatever it is the reward to train the
value function is function a few
exceptions around addiction it's
actually very very robust
>> and longer teenager that's learning to
drive
>> they start to drive and they already
have a sense of how they're driving
>> immediately
>> how confident
>> and then they see Okay. And they and
then of course the the learning speed of
any teenager is so fast. After 10 hours
you're good to go.
>> Yeah. It seems like humans have some
solution but I'm curious about like well
how are they doing it and like why is it
so hard?
>> I get to go do that in a month or two. I
never bothered to do it
>> to make something like this possible.
>> You know that is a great question to ask
and it's a question I have a lot of
opinions about.
But unfortunately
we live in a world where not not all
machine learning ideas are discussed
freely and this is this is one of them.
So there's probably a way to do it.
I think it can be done. The fact that
people are like that I think it's a
proof that it can be done. There may be
another blocker though which is there is
a possibility
that
>> the human neurons actually do more
compute than we think
>> and if that is true
>> that'd be funny
>> if that plays an important role then
things might be more difficult but
regardless I do think it points to the
existence of some
machine learning principle that I have
opinions on but unfortunately
circumstances make it hard to to discuss
in detail. Even though that's why you
raise money, man.
>> Got to keep everything secret.
>> I have to say that prepping for Ilia was
pretty tough because neither I nor
anybody else had any idea what he's
working on and what SSI is trying to do.
I had no basis to come up with my
questions and the only thing I could go
off honestly was trying to think from
first principles about what are the
bottlenecks to AGI because clearly Ilia
is working on them in some way. Part of
this question involved thinking about RL
scaling because everybody's asking how
well RL will generalize and how we can
make it generalize better. As part of
this, I was reading this paper that came
out recently on RL scaling and it showed
that actually the learning curve on RL
looks like a sigmoid. I found this very
curious. Why should it be a sigmoid?
Where it learns very little for a long
time and then it quickly learns a lot
and it asmmptotes. This is very
different from the power law you see in
pre-training where the model learns a
bunch at the very end. You got the
metric and less over time. And it
actually reminded me of a note that I
had written down after I had a
conversation with a researcher friend
where he pointed out that the number of
samples that you need to take in order
to find a correct answer scales
exponentially with how different your
current probability distribution is from
the target probability distribution. And
I was thinking about how these two ideas
are related. I had this vague idea that
they should be connected, but I really
didn't know how. I don't have a math
background, so I couldn't really
formalize it. But I wondered if Gemini 3
could help me out here. And so I took a
picture of my notebook and I took the
paper and I put them both in the context
of Gemini 3 and I asked it to find the
connection. And it thought a bunch and
then it realized that the correct way to
model the information you gain from a
single yes or no outcome in RL is as the
entropy of a random binary variable. It
made a graph which showed how the bits
you gain for a sample in RL versus
supervised learning scale as a pass rate
increases. And as soon as I saw the
graph that Gemini 3 made, immediately a
ton of things started making sense to
me. Then I wanted to see if there was
any empirical basis to this theory. So I
asked Gemini to code on my experiment to
show whether the improvement in loss
scales in this way with pass rate. I
just took the code that Gemini outputed.
I copy pasted it into a Google Collab
notebook and I was able to run this toy
ML experiment and visualize its results
without a single bug. It's interesting
because the results look similar but not
identical to what we should have
expected. And so I downloaded this chart
and I put it into Gemini and I asked it
what is going on here. I came up with a
hypothesis that I think is actually
correct which is that we're capping how
much supervised learning can improve in
the beginning by having a fixed learning
rate and in fact we should decrease the
learning rate over time. It actually
gives us an intuitive understanding for
why in practice we have learning rate
schedulers that decrease the learning
rate over time. I did this entire flow
from coming up with this vague initial
question to building a theoretical
understanding to running some toy ML
experiments all with Gemini 3. This
feels like the first model where it can
actually come up with new connections
that I wouldn't have anticipated. It's
actually now become the default place I
go to when I want to brainstorm new ways
to think about a problem. If you want to
read more about RL scaling, you can
check out the blog post that I wrote
with a little help from Gemini 3. And if
you want to check out Gemini 3 yourself,
go to gemini.google.
>> You say we are back.
>> I let the ad play and that was the most
effective possible ad for not
outsourcing your thinking that anyone
could have given me. It's very simple.
If you outsource your thinking, you have
zero value. That's it.
>> You come up with [ __ ] like that.
You were there from 2012 to 2020
and do yeah what what is now the vibe
going to be if we go back to the era of
research for example
even after Alex met the amount of
compute that was used to run experiments
kept increasing and the size of frontier
systems kept increasing
and do you think now that this era of
research will still require tremendous
amounts of compute Um do you think it
will require going back into the
archives and reading old papers? What is
maybe what was the vibe of like you were
at Google and um OpenAI and Stanford
these places when there was like a more
of a vibe of research. What what kind of
thing should we be expecting in the
community? So,
>> expect RL to work in the next year or
two for small models.
>> Scaling is
>> with tons of data exabytes.
>> Um, scaling sucked out all the air in
the room.
>> Yep. This is this is precisely my
complaint about LM. All right. LM are
awesome. They should take up 80% of the
resources, not 99. There are literally
fewer resources for RL now than before
all of the language model boom despite
the huge amount of extra money injected
by that cuz it's all gone to scaling
[ __ ] Like pretty much all of the
smartest people I know in RL as well,
they no longer do it. They now work at
language model companies that pay them a
lot of money. So lo and behold, zero
zero progress got made in RL from 2019
till 2024.
So
because scaling sucked out all the air
in the room,
everyone started to do the same thing.
We got to the point where
uh we are in a world where there are
more companies than ideas by quite a
bit. actually on that you know there is
this Silicon Valley saying that says
that ideas are cheap,
>> execution is everything
>> and people say that a lot.
>> Yeah.
>> And there is truth to that.
>> But then I saw I saw someone say on
Twitter um something like if ideas are
are so cheap, how come no one's having
any ideas?
>> I got ideas.
>> And I think it's true too. I think
>> like if you think about um a research
progress in terms of bottlenecks,
>> there are several bottlenecks.
>> If you go back to if you and um one of
them is ideas and one of them is your
ability to bring them to life.
>> Yeah.
>> Which might be compute but also
engineering.
>> Yep. Pure pure hard and fail.
>> That was RL in a nutshell. They killed
our own field. And if they had much
larger computers, maybe they could
demonstrate that their ideas were
viable. But they could not. So they
could only have very very small
demonstration that did not convince
anyone.
>> Yeah.
The Schmidt Huber
>> then in the
>> Schmid Huber is so mad in a nutshell,
right? Because like the guy actually had
a bunch of cool ideas and a bunch of
cool research and now he sees like
everybody getting all this recognition
for basically like copy paste same idea
with more compute, right?
like he's got some merit in it as well.
>> Computers increased a lot and of course
there is a question of how much
computers needed but compute is large.
So comput is large enough such that
it's like not obvious that you need that
much more compute to prove some idea.
Like I'll give you an analogy. Alexet
was built on two GPUs. It was my first
paper
>> total amount of comput use for it.
>> The transformer
>> it was not a good paper but
>> was built on 8 to 64 GPUs. No single
transformer paper experiment used more
than 64 GPUs of 2017 which would be like
what two GPUs of today.
>> So the ResNet
>> the one shady thing about that is then
Google has a ton of GPUs to run like a
ton of experiments in parallel. So if
you're in an academic lab, you're kind
of just screwed because you get to run
one experiment and hope it works. Like
I've seen this firsthand. So up an order
of magnitude or two for that,
>> right? Many like even even the the um
you could argue that the like 01
reasoning
>> was not the most computer heavy thing in
the world. So there definitely
for for research
you need like definitely some amount of
compute
>> but it's far from obvious that you need
the absolutely largest amount of compute
ever for research.
You might argue and I think it is
>> what I got behind me got.
>> If you want to build the absolutely best
system, if you want to build the
absolutely best system,
>> then it helps to have much more compute
and especially if everyone is within the
same paradigm,
then compute becomes one of the big
differentiators.
>> Yeah, I guess while it was possible to
develop these ideas, I'm asking you for
the history because you were actually
there. I'm not sure what actually
happened, but it sounds like it was
possible to develop these ideas using
minimal amounts of compute, but it
wasn't the transformer didn't
immediately become famous. It became the
thing everybody started doing and then
started experimenting on top of and
building on top of because it was
validated at higher and higher levels of
>> Yeah, it's not even clear that you need
the transformer to be honest.
>> SSI have ideas. How will you know which
one is the next transformer and which
one is
>> honestly was just scale more
>> without
having the kinds of compute that other
frontier labs have. So I can I can
comment on that which is
the short comment is that you know you
mentioned SSI specifically for us
the amount of compute that SSI has for
research is really not that small and I
want to explain why like a simple math
can explain why the amount of compute
that we have is actually a lot more
comparable for research than one might
think.
Now explain. So
SSI has raised $3 billion which is like
>> a lot of money
>> small by it's like a lot by any absolute
sense but you could say but look at the
other companies raising
>> much more
but a lot of what their a lot of their
comput goes for inference.
>> Yeah
>> like these big numbers these big loans
it's earmarked for inference. That's
number one. Number two, you need if you
want to have a product on which you do
inference, you need to have a big staff
of engineers, salespeople. A lot of the
research needs to be dedicated for
producing all kinds of product related
features. So then when you look at
what's actually left for research, the
difference becomes a lot smaller.
>> Yeah, he's very happy. he got unlimited
budget to do research
>> is that if you are doing something
different do you really need the
absolute maximum scale
>> to prove it? I don't think it's true at
all. I think that in our case we have
sufficient compute to prove to convince
ourselves and anyone else that what
we're doing is correct. Yep.
>> There's been public estimates that you
know companies like OpenAI spend on the
order of five six billion dollars a year
even just so far on experiments.
>> Google's the most company on inference
and so forth. So seems like they're
spending more a year running exper like
research experiment
>> than you guys have in total funding.
>> More efficient than Google.
>> It's a question of what you do with it.
It's a question of what you do with it.
like they have a like the more I think
in in in their case in the case of
others I think there's a lot more demand
on the training compute there's a lot
more different work streams there is
there are different modalities there is
just more stuff and so it becomes
fragmented
>> how will SSI make money
>> you know [snorts]
my answer to this question is something
like
we just f right now we just focus on the
research and then the answer to that
will reveal itself. I think there will
be lots of possible answers.
>> Chill.
>> Is SSI's plan still to straight shot
super intelligence?
>> Maybe. Maybe.
>> I think that there is merit to it. I
think there's a lot of merit because I
think that it's very nice to not be
affected by the day-to-day market
competition.
But
>> I think there are two reasons that may
cause us to change the plan. One is
pragmatic if timelines turn out to be
long
which they might and second I think
there is a lot of value in the best and
most powerful AI being out there
impacting the world.
>> Yeah,
>> I think this is a meaningfully valuable
thing.
>> But then so why is your default plan to
straight shot super intelligence? is it
sounds like you know OpenAI anthropic
all these other companies their explicit
thinking is look we have weaker and
weaker intelligences that the public can
get used to and prepare for and why is
it potentially better
>> yeah but clearly like these companies
aren't really doing anything they're no
longer innovating
>> the case for and against
>> yeah the case for is that you are so one
of the challenges
that people face when they're in the
market is that they have to participate
in the rat
Yeah.
>> And the rat race is quite the rat race
exposes you to to to difficult
trade-offs which you need
>> and there is it is it is nice to say
we'll insulate ourselves from all this
and just focus on the research and come
out only when we are ready and not
before. But the counterpoint is valid
too. And those those are opposing
forces. The counterpoint is hey it is
useful for the world to see powerful AI.
It is useful for the world to see
powerful AI because that's the only way
you can communicate it.
>> Well I guess not even just
>> I had to thread that needle with puffer
but obviously way smaller scale.
>> No the idea communicate the AI.
>> What do you mean communicate the AI? So,
okay. So, let's suppose you read an
essay about AI
>> and the essay says AI is going to be
this and AI is going to be that and it's
going to be this
>> and you read it and you say okay this is
an interesting essay
>> right
>> now suppose you see an AI doing this and
AI doing that
>> it is incomparable
>> like basically I think I think that
>> so yl like I don't even care people are
going to see it in a couple years
>> being in the public
>> I don't have to convince anybody they'll
see it in a couple years
>> that would be a reason for us to not be
quite straight shot.
>> Yeah. Well, I guess it's not even that
which I but I do think that is an
important part of it. The other big
thing is
>> they're going to show us some stuff.
>> I can't think of another discipline in
human engineering and research where
the end artifact was made safer mostly
through just thinking about how to make
it safe as opposed to why are airplane
crashes per mile so much lower today
than they were decades ago? Why is it so
much harder to find a bug in Linux than
it would have been decades ago? And I
think it's mostly because these systems
were deployed to the world. You noticed
failures. Those failures were corrected
and the systems became more robust. Now,
I'm not sure why AGI and superhuman
intelligence would be any different,
especially given, and I hope we can talk
we're going to get to this.
seems like the harms of super
intelligence are not just about like
having some malevolent uh paper clipper
out there, but it just like this is a
really powerful thing and we don't even
know how to conceptualize how people
interact with it, what people will do
with it
>> and having access to it seems like a
>> um
>> this is probably my main disagreement
with Ilia is like open source everything
for it. Well, I think I think on this
point even in the straight shot
scenario, you would still do a gradual
release of it is how I would imagine it
>> also fair.
>> The gra gradualism would be an inherent
inherent component of any plan. It's
just a question of what is the first
thing that you get out of the door.
That's number one. Number two, I also
think you know I believe you have
advocated for continual learning more
than other people
>> and I actually think that this is an
important and correct thing and here is
why
>> the things
>> buffer is everything in our except LMS.
We do small superhuman models
specialized to everything from games,
drones, autonomous driving. We just
released uh compute simulator, a compute
marketplace sim, done other stuff with
other companies. We build high
performance custom sims and then train
tiny models on pabytes or more of data.
>> So I'll give you another example of how
thinking how language affects thinking
and in this case this will be two words
two words that have shaped everyone's
thinking. I maintain
fir first word agi
second word pre-training
>> let me explain so
>> the word
>> susceptible to one of these
>> why does this term exist
>> it's a very particular term why does it
exist
>> oh do I get to link my article
>> the reason that the term AGI exists is
in my opinion not so much because it's
like a very important essential
descriptor of of some end state of
intelligence but
>> motivator
>> because it is a reaction to a different
term that existed and the term is narrow
AI. If you go back to ancient history of
gameplay AI of checkers AI, chess AI,
computer games AI, everyone would say
look at this narrow intelligence. Sure,
the chess AI can beat Casper off but it
can't do anything else. It is so narrow
artificial narrow intelligence. So in
response as a reaction
>> to this some people said well this is
not good it is so narrow what we need is
general
>> yeah see so my response to this is okay
screw it I'm going to make these narrow
superhuman AIs that you can train on one
GPU at home and make it stupidly easy to
do this across a huge number of domains
and I'm going to do it without needing
any funding because it's so cheap
>> general an AI that can just do all the
things.
The second and and that term just got a
lot of traction.
>> Yeah.
>> The second thing that got a lot of
traction is pre-training.
Specifically, the recipe of
pre-training. I think the current the
way people do RL now is maybe um un is
undoing the conceptual imprint of
pre-training.
>> Not taxing.
You do more pre-training,
>> the model gets better at everything more
or less uniformly.
>> General AI pre-training gives AGI
but
>> you can do this with RL too.
>> Happened with AGI. So my alternative
model for AGI and this is what I pitched
to him while I was at OpenAI is instead
of doing supervised learning just build
like a ridiculously big and complex sim
that encompasses all the things you
actually care about make it super fast
and just chug through huge amounts of
data. Um I think that probably we would
not be as far if you'd listened to me on
that one as we are today in AI as a
whole. But I think we are missing
something long term that that approach
will give us. And that's kind of what
I'm demonstrating lately through all the
RL that I've been doing, right? Like
these guys keep spending more and more
and more money and I'm on the other hand
spending less and less and less money
because it's getting faster and faster
and faster for better and better
capabilities
>> in pre-training is that in some sense
they overshot the target.
>> He just like he just had a bigger bet on
like compress everything. It was
compression at the time was the idea,
right? Like what if we just compress
everything? What about compression is
learning
>> because by the kind
>> liberty you could but like text is
really obnoxious because you tend to
need a bigger model to process the
inputs. It's like how you need a bigger
model to process pixels but on a much
different scale.
>> And if you think about the term AGI you
will realize and especially in the
context of pre-training you will realize
that a human being is not an AGI
because a human being yes there is
definitely a foundation of skills.
>> All right. All right. All right. All
right. Look, look, look, look, look. The
definition of AI or AGI has been
settled. I got sick of all the AGI
discussions at lunch at OpenAI. So, I
came up with this definition. Maybe a
couple of the people remember it. Maybe
they just maybe they it's too ridiculous
to uh where is it? You can read this on
X. There's AGI when I can cast fireball.
There you go.
That's the definition.
A human being,
a human being lacks a huge amount of
knowledge. Instead, we rely on continual
learning. We rely on continual learning.
And so then when you think about okay,
so let's suppose that we achieve success
and we produce a safe super some kind of
safe super intelligence. The question is
but how do you define it? Where on the
curve of continual learning is going to
be? I produce like
>> a super intelligent 15 year old that's
very eager to go and you say okay I'm
going to make
>> sci-fi not very much at all the great
student very eager
>> you go and be a programmer you go and be
a doctor
>> hello ai please solve cancer and aging
and scarcity
>> will involve some kind of a learning
trial and error period
>> there go there's your bar
>> it's a process as opposed to you drop
the finished thing
>> okay I I I see so you're you're
suggesting
that the thing you're pointing out with
super intelligence is not some finished
mind which knows how to do every single
job in the economy because the way say
the original I think open charter or
whatever defines AGI is like do every
single job [laughter] that every single
thing a human can do.
>> You're proposing instead a mind which
can learn to do any single every single
job.
>> Yes.
>> And that is super intelligence. And then
but once you have the learning algorithm
>> now doing every job is boring
>> the same way a human laborer might get
us into sci-fi era where bets are off.
>> It seems like one of these two things
might happen. Maybe neither of these
happens.
>> I don't give a [ __ ] about automating
existing work.
>> Super efficient learning algorithm
becomes
as good as you and potentially
even better at the task of ML research.
as a result the algorithm itself becomes
more and more superhuman. The other is
even if that doesn't happen. If you have
a single model, I mean this is explicit
your vision. If you have a single model
or instances of a model which are
deployed through the economy doing
different jobs, learning how to do those
jobs, continually learning on the job,
picking up all the skills that any human
can pick up but actually picking them
all up at the same time and then
amalgamating the learnings.
you basically have a model which
functionally becomes super intelligent
even without any sort of recursive
self-improvement in software right
because you now have one model that can
do every single job in the economy and
humans can't merge our minds in the same
way and so do you expect some sort of
like explosion from broad deployment
>> I think that it is likely that we will
have rapid economic growth
>> yeah
that's not interesting enough to
Like there are two arguments you could
make which are conflicting.
One is that look, if indeed you get once
indeed you get to a point where you have
an AI that can learn to do
things quickly and you have many of
them, then they will then there will be
a strong force to deploy them in the
economy unless there will be some kind
of a regulation that stops it, which by
the way there might be.
>> Yeah.
>> But I think the idea thing about our
>> rapid economic growth for some
>> prevent deploying models
>> from broad deployment. The other
question is how rapid it's going to be.
>> So I think this is hard to know because
on the one hand you have this very
efficient worker. On the other hand
there is the world is just really big
and there's a lot of stuff
and that stuff moves at a different
speed. But then on the other hand now
the AI could
>> you can literally if your thing is
actually AI like an AGI and not [ __ ]
like I don't need more than my computer
and sitting here to make a company and
like these things should be and there
are a lot of problems that can just be
solved by a dude sitting at a computer
who's smart enough and works long
enough. Um, so far AI has done none of
this. So that'd be a good initial bar,
>> you know. So I think very rapid economic
growth is possible and we will see like
all kinds of things like different
countries with different rules and the
ones which have the friendlier rules,
the economic growth will be faster. Hard
to predict.
>> Some people in our audience like to read
the restroom instead of listening to the
episode.
>> I will let this play.
>> I will do him the favor of not
commenting his ad.
>> Read like they are standalone essays.
The problem is that if you just
transcribe a conversation verbatim using
a speech to text model, it'll be full of
all kinds of fits and starts and
confusing phrasing. We mentioned this
problem to Labelbox and they asked if
they could take a stab. Working with
them on this is probably the reason that
I'm most excited to recommend Labelbox
to people. It wasn't just, oh, hey, tell
us what kind of data you need and we'll
go get it. They walked us through the
entire process from helping us identify
what kind of data we needed in the first
place to assembling a team of expert
aligners to generate it. Even after we
got all the data back, Labelbox stayed
involved. They helped us choose the
right base model and set up auto QA on
the model's output so that we could
tweak and refine it. And now we have a
new transcriber tool that we can use for
all our episodes moving forward. This is
just one example of how Labelbox meets
their customers at the ideas level and
partners with them through their entire
journey. If you want to learn more or if
you want to try out the transcriber tool
yourself, go to labelbox.com/barcash.
It seems to me that this is a very
precarious situation to be in where
looking the limit we know that this
should be possible because if you have
something that is as good as a human at
learning but which can merge its brains
merge there are different instances in a
way that humans can't merge already.
This seems like a thing that should be
possible. Humans are possible digital
computers are possible. So, you just
need
>> I I can't [ __ ] on the ad because I don't
know what it was.
>> It seems to me that this is a very
precarious situation to be in where
look the limit. We know that this should
be possible because if you have
something that is as good as a human at
learning but which can merge its brains
merge there are different instances in a
way the humans can't merge already. This
seems like a thing that should
physically be possible. Humans are
possible digital computers are possible.
You just need both of those combined to
produce this thing. And it also seems
like this kind of thing is
extremely um powerful.
>> No liberty
>> and economic grow growth is one way to
put it. Um I mean Dyson spear is a lot
of economic growth but another way to
put
>> Dyson spear is way more exciting than
economic growth
>> potentially a very short period of time
and
>> you know you you're hiring people at SSI
in six months they're like net
productive probably right um a human
like learns really fast and so this
thing is becoming smarter and smarter
very fast
>> six months they're net
go well
>> six days out position to do that well
>> hours plan basically is what I'm trying
to ask
>> so one of the one of the ways in which
my thinking has been changing is that
I now place more importance on AI
being
deployed
incrementally and in advance. One very
difficult thing about AI is that we are
talking about systems that don't yet
exist
and it's hard to imagine them.
I think that one of the things that's
happening is that in practice it's very
hard to feel the AGI.
It's very hard to feel the AGI.
We can talk about it.
>> Yeah. It's most [ __ ]
>> It's like talking about like the long f
like imagine like having a conversation.
How is it like to be old
>> when you're like old and frail? And you
can have a conversation. you can try to
imagine it, but
it's just hard and you come back to
reality where that's not the case. And I
think that a lot of the issues around
AGI and its future power stem from the
fact that it's very difficult to imagine
future AI is going to be diff different.
It's going to be powerful. Indeed, the
whole problem, what is the problem of AI
and AGI? The whole problem is the
problem.
>> It's not even sci-fi fantasy. That would
be like the cool [ __ ] That's like what
I get up in the morning because of,
right? It's like, maybe we can just like
solve one problem that then solves aging
and disease and scarcity and like my
lack of being able to cast fireball or
run a three minute mile. like you know
>> problem is the power
when the power is really big what's
going to happen
and one of the one of the ways in which
I've changed my mind over the past year
and so that that change of mind may back
may I'll say I I'll I'll hedge a little
bit may back propagate into into the
plans of our of our company is that
so if it's hard to imagine
Uhhuh.
>> What do you do? You got to be showing
the same. You got to be showing the
same. And I maintain that. I think I
think most people who work on AI also
can't imagine it because it's too
different from what people see.
>> I can imagine a lower bound on it. I can
think of some problems I'd like to be
solved
>> that are mostly bound by us being too
stupid to solve them
>> on a day-to-day basis.
I do maintain
>> I actually like one of the things that
drives me crazy is like oh like you know
when I meet AI people there's like oh we
need AGI so I can have household chore
robot I'm like are you [ __ ] me
that's all you can think of really
>> here's something which I predict will
happen that's a prediction
I maintain
>> at the moment hyper it was open AI
though in 2019
>> is more powerful
than people who change their behaviors
And we will see all kinds of
unprecedented things which are not
happening right now. And I'll give some
examples. I do like I I think I think
for better or worse the the frontier
companies will play a very important
role in what happens as with the
government
>> and the kind of things that I think
you'll see
>> which
>> you see the beginnings of
companies that are fierce competitors
starting collaborate to collaborate on
AI safety. You may have seen openthropic
eval
>> doing a first small step but that did
not exist. That's actually something
which I predicted in my talks about
three years ago that such a thing will
happen.
>> I also maintain that as AI continues to
become more powerful more visibly
powerful there will also be a desire
from governments and the public to do
something
and
>> that's worst possible case
>> do not slow down the engine of progress
>> number one. Number two. Okay. So then
the AI is being built. What needs to
what needs to be done?
So one thing that I maintain that will
happen is that right now people who are
working on AI, I maintain that the AI
doesn't feel powerful because of its
mistakes.
I do think that at some point the AI
will start to feel powerful actually.
And I think when that happens, we will
see a big change in the way
all AI companies approach safety.
They'll become much more paranoid. I
think I I say this is a predict as a as
a as a prediction that we will see
happen. We'll see if I'm right, but I
think this is something that will happen
because they will see the AI becoming
more powerful. I don't know about that
man
>> right now I maintain is because people
look at today's AI and it's hard to
imagine the future AI
>> quite easy to imagine
>> the third thing which needs to
>> and I think this is this this and I'm
talking about it in in broader terms not
just from the perspective of SSI
because you asked me about our company
but the question is okay so then what
should what should the companies aspire
to build
>> what should they aspire to build and
there has been one big idea that
actually every that um everyone has been
locked in locked into which is the the
self-improving AI
and why why did it happen because there
is fewer ideas than companies but I
maintain that
>> it doesn't work right
>> it's better to be
>> and I think that everyone will actually
want that it's like the AI that's
robustly aligned to care about sentient
life specifically
I think in particular it will
There's a case to be made that it will
be easier to build an AI that cares
about sentient life than an AI that
cares about human life alone because the
AI itself will be sentient.
And if you think about things like
mirror neurons and human empathy for
animals, which is, you know, you might
argue it's not big enough, but it
exists.
>> Anybody know goes to Burning Man? fact
that we model others with the same
circuit that we used to model ourselves
because that's the most efficient thing
to do. So
>> even care about sentient beings
>> and it's not actually clear to me that
that's what you should try to do
alignment.
>> It would still be the case that most
sentient beings will be AIS. There will
be trillions eventually quadrillions of
AIs. Humans will be a very small
fraction of sentient beings.
So, it's not clear to me if the goal is
some kind of human control over
this future civilization
that this is the best criterion.
>> It's true.
>> I I think that
it's possible it's not the best
criterion.
>> I'll say two things. I think that thing
number one
I think that if there so
I think that care for sentient life I
think there is merit to it. I think it
should be considered. I think that it
will be helpful if there was some kind
of a
short list of ideas that then the
companies when they are in this
situation could use. That's number two.
Number three, I think it would be really
materially helpful if the power of the
most powerful super intelligence was
somehow capped
because it would address a lot of these
concerns.
>> No,
>> the question of how to do it, I'm not
sure. But I think that would be
materially helpful when you're talking
about really really powerful systems.
>> Yeah. Um before we continue the
alignment discussion, I I want to double
click on that. How much room is there at
the top? How do you think about super
intelligence? Do you think I mean using
this learning efficiency idea maybe is
just extremely fast at learning new
skills or new knowledge and does it just
have a bigger pool of strategies? Is
there a single cohesive it in the center
that's more powerful or bigger? And if
so,
do you do you imagine that this will be
sort of godlike in comparison to the
rest of human civilization or does it
just feel like another agent or another
cluster of agents?
So this is an area where different
people have different intuitions.
>> I think it will be very powerful for
sure. I think that what I think is most
likely to happen
is that there will be multiple
such AIS being created roughly at the
same time.
I think that
>> not if you slow down the other guys not
worried about the safety
>> like if the cluster is literally
continent sized that thing could be
really powerful indeed right if you
literally have a continentsized cluster
like those those AIs can be very
powerful and I like
>> probably don't that
>> is that if you're talking about
extremely powerful AIs like truly
dramatically powerful then yeah it would
be nice if they could be restrained
in some ways or if there was some kind
of agreement,
>> good luck something
because I think that if you are saying
hey like if if you really like what what
is the the concern of super intelligence
what is one way to explain the concern
if you imagine a system that is
sufficiently powerful like really
sufficiently powerful and you could say
okay you need to do something sensible
like care for sentient life let's say in
a very singleminded way you might not
like the results. That's really what it
is. And so maybe by the way the answer
is that you do not build a single you do
not build an RL agent in the usual
sense. And actually I'll point I'll
point several things out. I think human
beings are a semi agent. You know we
pursue a reward and then the emotions or
whatever make us tire out of the reward.
We pursue a different reward.
The market is like kind it's like a very
shortsighted kind of agent. Evolution is
the same. Evolution is very intelligent
in some ways but very dumb in other
ways. The government has been designed
to be a never- ending fight between
three parts which has an effect. So I
think this [laughter]
>> that's the most statement of all
statements is that we are talking about
systems that don't exist that we don't
know how to build.
Right? And that's the other thing and
that's actually my belief. I think the
people that I do know how to build
>> and then peter out. It will continue to
improve but it will also not be it. So
the it we don't know how to build and I
think that a lot h a lot hinges on
understanding reliable generalization.
And I'll say another thing which is like
you know one of the things that you
could say is what that cause alignment
to be difficult is that human that it's
it's um
your ability to learn human values is
fragile then your ability to optimize
them is fragile. Will you actually learn
to optimize them? And then can't you say
are these not all instances of
unreliable generalization?
Why is it that human beings appear to
generalize so much better? What if
generalization was much better? What
would happen in this case? What would be
the effect? But those we can't we can't
like those questions are right now still
unanswerable.
>> Um how does one think about what AI
going well looks like? Because I think
you've scoped out how AI might evolve.
We'll have these sort of continual
learning agents. AI will be very
powerful. Maybe there will be many
different AIs. How do you think about
lots of continent computes size
intelligences going around? How
dangerous is that? How do we make that
less dangerous? And how do we do that in
a way that
protects a equilibrium where there might
be misaligned AIs out there and bad
actors out there?
>> These safety people are like
before we even have solved the problem
to have all the good that can come out
of that. They're like coming up with
hypothetical evils that may or may not
even exist. one reason why I liked the
AI that cares for sentient life,
>> you know, and we can debate on whether
it's good or bad. But if the first N of
these dramatic systems actually do care
for, you know,
love humanity or something, you know,
care for sentient life, obviously this
also needs to be achieved. This needs to
be achieved.
So if this is achieved by the first end
of those systems
then then I can see it go well. I
actually do think that's possible,
hyper, but like it's sci-fi [ __ ] and
it's like we're not going to build a
continent-sized cluster ourselves,
right?
>> At least for quite some time. And then
there is the question of what happens in
the long run.
>> What happens in the long run? How do you
achieve a long run equilibrium?
>> And I think that there there is an
answer as well and I don't like this
answer
but it needs to be considered.
In the long run, you might say, okay, so
if you have a world where powerful AI
exist. In the short term, you could say,
okay, you have universal high income.
You have universal high income and we
all doing well. But we know that what do
the Buddhists say? Change is the only
constant. And so things change and there
is some kind of government political
structure thing and it changes because
these things have a shelf life. You
know, some new government thing comes up
and it functions and then after some
time it stops functioning.
That's something that you see happening
all the time. And so I think that for
the long run equilibrium
one approach you could say okay so maybe
every person will have an AI that will
do their bidding and that's good and if
that could be maintained indefinitely
that's true but the downside with that
is okay so then
>> the AI goes and like earns earn earn you
know earns money for for the person and
you know advocates for their needs like
nothing fear
>> and maybe then writes a little report
saying okay here's what I've done here's
the situation and the person says great
keep it up
>> but the person is no longer a
participant
and then you can say that's a precarious
place to be in but so I'm going to
preface by saying
I don't like this solution but it is a
solution
And the solution is if people become
part AI with some kind of neural link++
because what will happen as a result is
that now the AI understands something
and we understand it too like
because now the understanding is
transmitted wholesale. So now if the AI
is in some situation now it's like you
are involved in the situation yourself
fully
and I think this is the answer to the
equilibrium. I wonder if uh the fact
that emotions which were
developed
millions or in many cases billions of
years ago in a totally different
environment are still guiding our
actions so strongly.
>> I wonder why he's talking about this
[ __ ] It's probably just like
>> to maybe spell out what I
>> doesn't want to give up much about what
he's actually doing.
>> The brain stem has these
>> I don't know if it's more accurate to
call it a value function or reward
function, but the brain stem has a
directive where it's saying mate with
somebody who's more successful. The
cortex is the part
>> he did not literally say nothing the
entire podcast. Ryan like Ilia is
actually I think in AI he is probably
the best speaker in AI
like I remember and it's he's still the
same way. He speaks with such an
intention an intentionality and a
clarity.
Oops.
Uh yeah such an intentionality and a
clarity.
Yeah.
that understands what does success mean
in the modern context
>> finish this
>> the brain stem is able to align
>> the cortex and say however you recognize
success to be and I'm not smart enough
to understand what that is
>> you're still going to pursue this
directive
>> I think I think there is
so I think there's a more general point
>> I think it's actually really mysterious
how the brain encodes high level desires
sorry how evolution encodes high level
desires
>> like it's pretty easy to understand how
evolution would would endow us with the
desire for food that smells good because
smell is a chemical
and so just pursue that chemical. It's
very easy to imagine such a me evolution
doing such a thing. But evolution also
has has endowed us with all these social
desires like we we really care about
being seen positively by society. We
care about being in a good standing. the
like all these social intuitions that we
have I feel strongly that they are baked
in and I don't know how evolution did it
because it's a high level concept it's
represented in the brain like what
people think like let's say you are like
you care about
some social thing
it's not like a low-level signal like
smell it's not something that for which
there's a sensor like the brain needs to
do a lot of processing to piece together
lots of bits of information to
understand what's going on socially and
somehow evolution said that's what you
should care about
>> yes
>> I definitely take
Ilia uh Andre Andrew for sure
>> how did you do it and he did it quickly
too
>> because I think all these sophisticated
social things that um we care about I
think they evolved pretty recently
>> so evolution had an easy time hard
coding this high level desire and I
maintain or you know at least I'll say
I'm unaware of good hypothesis for how
it's done. And I I had some ideas I was
kicking around, but none of them.
>> But if you want to do all this social
stuff, like this is the exact thing that
you would build a big sim for.
And like if you want to know how stuff
emerges, right, without grounding stuff
in human preconception,
this is exactly the type of stuff you
would do with my exact line of work with
Neural Mone and with all the other
things, right?
>> None of them uh are satisfying.
>> Yeah. And what's especially impressive
is if it was a desire that you learned
in your lifetime, it kind of makes sense
because your brain is intelligent. It
makes sense why we be able to learn
intelligent desires. But your point is
that the desire is maybe this is not
your point, but one way to understand it
is the desire is built into the genome
and the genome is not intelligent,
right? But it's able to you're somehow
able to describe this feature that
requires like it's not even clear how
you define that feature and you can get
it into the you can build it into the
genes. Yeah, essentially, or maybe I'll
put it differently. If you think about
the tools that are available to the
genome,
it says, "Okay, here's a recipe for
building a brain." And he could say,
"Here is a recipe for connecting the
dopamine neurons to like the smell
sensor."
>> Yeah. And if the smell about evolution
is useful, you know, good smell, you
want to eat that.
>> I could
>> He's no longer doing like pure LLM
stuff. Ryan, like
>> it makes sense. He's looking for other
stuff. The safety thing I actually don't
know and I never really got full context
on how he looks at this stuff from
OpenAI. There's definitely some weird
stuff there. Um, I'd say of the big
companies, like less weird than what the
hell Open AI and Anthropic are doing
now. Still weird. Imagine the genome
doing that. I'm claiming that it is
harder to imagine. It's harder to
imagine the genome saying you should
care about some complicated computation
that your entire brain that like a big
chunk of your brain does. That's all I'm
claiming. I I can tell you like a
speculation. I was wondering how it
could be done. And let me offer a
speculation and I'll explain why the
speculation is probably false.
So plum, there's a difference between
being a good speaker in the sense that
like, oh yeah, people like listening to
you. If that's your goal, go be a
politician and lie your ass off. And
there's and being a good technical
speaker who is actually precise and
intentional and correct more often than
everyone else.
>> So the speculation is okay. So the brain
it's like the brain has those regions
you know the brain regions we have our
cortex right
>> it has all those brain regions and the
cortex is uniform but the brain regions
and and and the neurons in the cortex
they kind of speak to their neighbors
mostly and that's explains why you get
brain regions because if you want to do
some kind of speech processing all the
neurons that do speech need to talk to
each other
>> and they can and because neurons can
only speak to their nearby neighbors for
the most part it has to be a region
All the regions are mostly located in
the same place from person to person. So
maybe evolution hardcoded literally a
location on the brain.
>> So it says oh like when when like you
know the GPS of the brain GPS
fires that's what she care about like
maybe that's what evolution did because
that would be within the toolkit of
evolution.
>> Yeah. Although there
>> eccentric
observe the bounty behind you.
>> There are examples where for example
people who are born blind have that area
of their cortex adopted by
another sense and I have no idea but I'd
be surprised if the desires or the
reward functions which require visual
signal no longer worked. you know,
people who have their different areas of
their cortex co-opted. For example, if
you no longer have vision,
can you still feel the sense that I want
people around me to like me and so
forth, which usually there's also visual
cues for.
>> So, I actually fully agree with that. I
I think there's an even stronger counter
argument to this theory,
>> which is like if you think about people,
so there are people who get half of
their brain removed in childhood.
>> Yeah. and they still have all their
brain regions, but they all somehow move
to just one hemisphere, which suggests
that the brain regions the the location
is not fixed. And so that theory is not
true. It would have been cool if it was
true, but it's not. And so I think
that's a mystery, but it's an
interesting mystery. Like the fact is
somehow
>> evolution was able to endow us to care
about social stuff very very reliably.
And even people who have like all kinds
of strange mental conditions and
deficiencies and emotional problems tend
to care about this. Also,
>> AI tools like defakes, voice clones, and
agents have dramatically actually
thinking about
stuff.
>> So, it's more important than ever to
actually understand the identity and
intent of whoever or whatever is using
your platform. That's exactly what
Sardine helps you do. Sardine brings
together thousands of device behavior
and identity signals to help you assess
risk. Everything from how a user types
or moves their mouse or holds their
device to whether they're hiding their
true location behind a VPN to whether
they're injecting a fake camera feed
during KYC selfie checks. Sardine
combines these signals with insights
from their network of almost 4 billion
devices. things like a user's history of
fraud or their associations with other
high-risisk accounts so you can spot bad
actors before they do damage. This would
literally be impossible if you only use
data from your own application. Sardine
doesn't stop at detection. They offer a
suite of agents to streamline onboarding
checks and automate investigations. So,
as fraudsters use AI to scale their
attacks, you can use AI to scale your
defenses. Go to sardine.ai/waresh.
AI/wark
to learn more and download their guide
on AI fraud detection.
What is SSI planning on doing
differently? So presumably your plan is
>> All right, enough of whatever the [ __ ]
this is in the comments.
>> And then what is
presumably you started SSI because
you're like I I think I have a way of
approaching how to do this safely in a
way that the other companies don't. What
what is that difference?
So the way I would describe it as
there are some ideas that I think are
promising and I want to investigate them
and see if they are indeed promising or
not. It's really that simple. It's an
attempt. I think that if the ideas turn
out to be correct, these ideas that we
discussed around understanding
generalization,
>> if these ideas turn out to be correct,
>> I mean, the one good thing about this is
I would think that with all the stuff
that he's thinking about, hopefully
we're not just going to get like some
slight variation of a language model out
of SSI. It seems like he has genuinely
like raised a bunch of money to go just
back to the drawing board and think
about stuff fully and that's pretty
awesome.
Then I think we will have something
worthy. Will it turn out to be correct?
We are doing research. We are squarely
age of research company.
>> Yeah,
>> we making progress. We've actually made
quite good progress over the past year,
but we need to keep making more
progress.
>> Does he mean he might try out his ideas?
Dude, do you know how many people will
raise? Like usually the opposite
happens. You raise $3 billion and you're
completely locked to a trajectory where
like it's obligation to investor this
quarter, that quarter, next like [ __ ]
that happens even way before $3 billion.
Companies go raise$ one or $200 million
and it's like you know completely
beholden with no freedom to do anything
interesting whatsoever.
>> More research and that's how I see it. I
see it as an attempt.
>> Yeah, I'd say so. Ryan,
>> an attempt to be a voice and a
participant.
>> Um, people have asked,
uh, your co-founder and previous CEO
left to go to Meta recently and people
have asked, well, if there was a lot of
breakthroughs being made, that seems
like a thing that should have been
unlikely. I wonder how you respond.
>> Yeah. So I in for for this I will simply
remind a few facts that may have been
forgotten and I think this these facts
which provide the context I think they
explain the situation. So the context
was that we were fundraising
to bill in valuation
and then Meta um came in and offered to
to acquire us and I said no
but my former co-founder
like in some sense said yes and as a
result he also was able to enjoy from a
lot of near-term liquidity
>> and he was the only person from SSI to
join Meta.
It sounds like SSI's plan is to be a
company that is at the frontier when you
get to this
very important period in human history.
>> I mean, I guess I I don't know his
co-founder like what he had originally.
People have different motivations,
right? Like
like Ilia presumably like Ilia has
enough personally that there's basically
nothing you can offer him that's going
to be more interesting to him than what
he's doing now, right? Like money
doesn't buy money only buys so much.
>> Where you have superhuman intelligence
and you have these ideas about how to
make superhuman intelligence go well but
other companies will be trying their own
ideas. What distinguishes SSI's approach
to making super intelligence go well.
>> The the main thing that distinguishes
SSI is its technical approach.
So we have a different technical
approach that I think
>> I don't know anything about Meera or
like her technical background
whatsoever, but I like I know Ilia's
research, right? I have no idea on what
basis Mirror was in the position she's
in. Maybe she does have good research. I
don't know anything about her though. I
know about Ilia. Uh I've seen Greg and
his engineering in action. Mirror wasn't
even there when I was there. Uh, I know
Altman and I know that I don't trust
him. Uh, what else the [ __ ] Who else?
Oh, I know Radford is awesome. Uh, I
know Schulman is very narrowly
the algorithms guy, but he's the best
algorithms guy.
>> Think he's worthy
and we pursuing it.
>> I maintain that.
>> Yeah, there's a little bit more to that
one though, Ryan. At the end there will
be a convergence of strategies. So I
think there will be a convergence of
strategies where
at some point as AI becomes more
powerful,
it's going to become more or less
clearer to everyone what the strategy
should be. And it should be something
like, yeah, you need to find some way to
talk to each other. And you want your
first
actual like real super intelligent AI to
be aligned and somehow be
you know care for sentient life, care
for people, democratic, one of those
some combination of their and I think
this is the condition
that everyone should strive for and
that's what the societ striving for and
I think that this time if not already
all the other companies will be
realizing they're striving towards the
same thing and we'll see I think that
the world will truly change as AI
becomes more powerful Yeah, I think
>> this is like so counting your chickens
before they hatch though, right? All
these like, oh well, what's AGI going to
look like? [ __ ] figure out how
to build it, right?
I still I take IA's take over Daarios or
Sam's, you know, by far
>> I think a lot of these forecasts will
like I think things will be really
different and people will be acting
really differently. What speaking of
forecasts, what are your forecasts to
this system you're describing which can
learn as well as a human and
subsequently as a result become
superhuman.
>> I think like uh 5 to 20
>> 5 to 20 years.
>> So I just want to unroll your
how you might see the world coming. It's
like we have a couple more years where
these other companies are continuing the
current approach and it stalls out and
stalls out here meaning they earn no
more than low hundreds of billions in
revenue or how do you think about what
stalling out means?
>> Yeah,
I think the re I think it could I think
it could stall out and
>> make a lot of money.
>> I think stalling out will look like
it will all look very similar.
>> Yeah.
>> Among all the different companies
something like this. I'm not sure
because I think I think I think even
with I think even I think even with
stolen out I think these companies could
make a stupendous stupendous revenue.
>> Yeah.
>> Maybe not profits because they will be
they will need to work hard to
differentiate each other from themselves
>> but revenue definitely.
>> Yeah.
>> But there's something in your model
implies that
>> I was just an intern when I was in
undergrad. I was there for six months
before I did my PhD.
>> When the correct
>> but I was there at a good time, right?
like that was in my eyes the golden age
of open AI. Dota in particular is the
coolest damn thing I've ever seen.
>> Solution does emerge, there will be
convergence between all the companies
and I'm curious why you think that's the
case.
>> Well, I was talking more about
convergence on their largest strategies.
>> I think eventual convergence on the
technical approach is probably going to
happen as well, but I I was alluding to
convergence to the larger strategies.
What what what exactly is the thing that
should be done?
>> I I just want to better understand how
you see the future unrolling. So
currently we have different expect to
continue generating revenue. Yes.
>> But not yet to this humanlike learner.
>> Yes.
>> So now we have these different forks of
companies. We have you we have thinking
machines. There's a bunch of other labs.
>> Yes.
>> And maybe one of them figures out the
correct approach.
>> Release of their product makes it clear
to other people how
>> small profitable.
>> I think it won't be clear how to do it
thing but it can be clear that something
different is possible
>> right
>> and that is information. And I think
people will will will then be trying to
figure out how how that's how that
works. I do think though that one of the
things that's that I think you know not
addressed here not discussed is that
with each increase in the AI's
capabilities I think there will be some
kind of changes but I don't know exactly
which ones in how things are being done.
So like I think it's going to be
important yet I can't spell out what
that is exactly.
>> And how how are the
by default you would expect the company
that has the model company that has that
model to be getting all these gains
because they have the model that is
learning how to do all has the skills
and knowledge that it's building up in
the world. What is the reason to think
that the benefits of that will be widely
distributed and not just that
>> whatever model company gets this
continuous learning loop going first?
>> I think that empirically what happen so
here here is what I think is going to
happen. Number one, I think empirically
when
but let's let's look at let's look at
how things have gone so far with um the
AIs of the past. So one company produced
an advance and the other company
scrambled and produced some competiti
some some similar things after some
amount of time and they started to
compete in the market and push their
push the prices down and so I think from
the market perspective I think something
similar will happen there as well even
if someone okay we're talking about the
good world by the way where
what's the good
What's the good world
where we have these powerful humanlike
learners that are also like and by the
way maybe there there's another thing we
haven't discussed on the on the the spec
of the super intelligent AI that I think
is
>> haven't tried TPent trick
>> is that you make it narrow
can be useful and narrow at the same
time. So you can have lots of narrow
super intelligent AIs. But suppose you
have many of them
and you have some and you have some
company that's producing a lot of um
profits from it and then you have
another company that comes in and starts
to compete and the way the competition
is going to work is through
specialization.
I think what's going to happen is that
>> in a way
competition like competition loves
specialization and you see it in the
market you see it in evolution as well.
So you're going to have lots of
different niches and you're going to
have lots of different companies who are
occupying different niches in
in this kind of world where you might
say yeah like one AI company is really
quite a bit better at some area of
really complicated economic activity and
a different company is better at another
area and the third company is really
good at litigation and
>> is this contradicted by what human like
learning implies is that like it can
learn
>> it can but but you have accumulated
learning you have a big investment. You
spent a lot of compute to become really
really really good really phenomenal at
this thing and someone else spent a huge
amount of comput and a huge amount of
experience to get really really good at
some other thing
>> right
>> you apply a lot of human learning to get
there but now like you you are at this
high point where someone else would say
look like I don't want to start learning
what you've learned to do
>> I guess that would require many
different companies to begin at the
human like continual learning agent at
the same time so that they can start
their different research in different
branches. But if one company,
you know, gets that agent first or gets
that learner first,
it does then seem like well, you know,
>> companies are all within a few years of
each other.
>> Every single job in the economy,
you just have uh instance learning each
one seems tractable for
>> Yeah, that's that's that's a valid
argument. My my strong int
>> I think I'd go with on this one.
>> Yeah. Like the argument says it will go
this way.
>> Yeah.
>> But my strong intuition is that it will
not work this way.
>> That this is the you know in in theory
there is no difference between theory
and practice. In practice there is. And
I think that's going to be one of those.
>> A lot of people's models of recursive
self-improvement literally explicitly
state we will have a million Ilias in a
server. They're coming up with different
ideas and this will lead to a super
intelligence emerging very fast. Do you
have some intuition about how
parallelizable the thing you are doing
is how how what are the gains from
making copies of Ilia?
>> I don't know.
>> Tremendous.
>> I think
>> we get a millionas when like all the
problems in the world are solved
>> because you want you want people who
think differently rather than the same.
I think that if they were literal copies
of me, I'm not sure how much more
>> that's so humble.
That is so humble, dude. Give me like
[laughter]
give me a hundred of me and one
be the biggest damn ego check in the
world and two and have a lot of cool
[ __ ] done.
>> But people who think differently, that's
what you want. Why is it that it's been
if you look at different models even
released by totally different companies
trained on potentially non-over
overlapping data sets, it's actually
crazy how similar LLMs are to each
other.
>> Maybe the data sets are not as non-over
overlapping as it seems.
>> But [laughter] there's there's some
sense there's like even if an individual
human might be less productive than the
future AI, maybe there's something to
the fact that human teams have more
diversity than teams of AIS might have.
But
>> human teams are generally a mess
diversity. among AI. So I think just
raising the temperature just results in
gibberish. I think you want something
more like different scientists have
different different prejudices or
different ideas. How do you get that
kind of
>> diversity among AI agents?
>> So the reason there has been no
diversity I believe is because of
pre-training
>> all the pre-trained models are the same
>> same data
>> pretty much because they're pre-trained
on the same data. Now RL and post
training is where some differentiation
starts to emerge because different
people
>> come up with different RL training.
>> Yeah.
>> And then I've heard you hint in the past
about selfplay as a way to either get
data or match agents to other agents of
equivalent intelligence to kick off
learning. How should we think about why
there's no public
um proposals of this kind of thing
working with LMS? I would say tough to
formulate.
>> I would say that
>> the reason why I thought selfplayful was
interesting
>> is because it offered a way to create
models using compute only without data
>> right and if you think that data is the
ultimate bottleneck then using compute
only is very interesting. So that's what
makes it interesting. Now the
the thing is
that selfplay at least the way It was
done in the past when you have agents
which somehow compete with each other.
It's only good for developing a certain
set of skills. It is too narrow.
>> Oh,
hell yeah.
He of little faith.
Open AI got out of Dota too early, man.
They got out of Dota too early. They
barely scratched the surface. Uh this is
one of the major major things you're
going to see in the next couple years.
good for like negotiation,
uh, conflict,
certain social skills,
strategizing, that kind of stuff. And so
if you care about those skills, then
self will be useful. Now, actually, I
think that selfplay
did
find a home, but just in a different
form, in a different form. So things
like debate, prove a verifier, you have
some kind of an LLM as a judge which is
also incentivized to find mistakes in
your work. You could say this is not
exactly selfplay not quite the same
though you know a related adversarial
setup that people are doing I believe
>> and really selfplay is an example of um
is a special case of more general like
competition between between agents
>> right the response the natural response
to competition is to try to be different
and so if you were to put multiple
agents
>> I literally I had I had a piece of work
on neural MMO one that showed this while
I was at open AAI it was really cool
like you literally would just let the
agents go and they'd all go in different
directions and like different models
would go in different learn to go in
different directions so that they would
like specialize differently and not
compete
>> and you tell them you know you all need
to work on some problem and you're an
agent
>> and you're inspecting what everyone else
is working
>> you're going to say well if they already
taking this approach it's not clear I
should pursue it I should pursue
something differentiate and so I think
that something like this could also
create an incentive for um a diversity
approaches.
>> Yeah. Um, final question.
What is research taste? You're obviously
the person in the world who is
considered to have the best taste in
doing research in AI. You were
uh the co-author on many of the biggest
the biggest things that have happened in
the history of deep learning from Alex
Net to GPT3 to so on. What is it that
how do you characterize how
you come up with these ideas?
>> I can answer. So I can comment on this
for myself.
>> I think different people do it
differently.
But one thing that um guides me
personally
is
an aesthetic
of how AI should be
>> by thinking about how people are but
thinking correctly.
>> Like it's very easy to think about how
people are incorrectly. But what is it?
Huh?
Does it mean to think about people
correctly?
>> So I'll give you some examples.
The idea of the artificial neuron is
directly inspired by the brain. And it's
a great idea. Why? Because you say sure
the brain has all these different
organs. It has the faults but the faults
probably don't matter.
>> Why do we think that the neurons matter?
Because there is many of them. It kind
of feels right. So you want the neuron.
>> Yeah.
>> You want some kind of local learning
rule that will change the connections.
You want some local learning rule rule
that will change the connections between
the neurons,
>> right? It feels plausible that the brain
does it. The idea of the distributed
representation,
the idea that the brain,
you know, the brain responds to
experience or neural network should
learn from experience, not response. The
brain learns from experience.
>> The neural net should learn from
experience. And you kind of ask yourself
is some is something fundamental or not
fundamental? How things should be?
>> Yeah.
>> And I think that's been guiding me a
fair bit. kind of thinking from multiple
angles and looking for almost beauty.
Beauty, simplicity, ugliness. There's no
room for ugliness. It's just beauty,
simplicity, elegance, correct
inspiration from the brain. And all of
those things need to be present at the
same time.
>> And the more they are present, the more
confident you can be in a top down
belief. And then the top down belief is
the thing that sustains you when the
experiments contradict you. Because if
you just trust the data all the time,
well, sometimes you can be doing a
correct thing, but there's a bug.
>> But you don't know that there is a bug.
How can you tell that there is a bug?
>> How do you know if you should keep
debugging or you conclude it's the wrong
direction?
>> Well, is the top down? Well, how should
>> man, this is like
this is true to an extent that is really
difficult
to convey to people who have not sunk
basically their entire life
um into research. the amount of mental
resilience
that research requires,
the amount of distractors, the amount of
like it's so easy to go with the flow of
what everyone is doing, but to actually
do something that is new and out there.
Um,
it requires such an incredibly strong
conviction on the path that you've taken
that it's like borderline madness.
But then of course the difference
between it being truly mad and simply
dedication that is required that you can
explain exactly what you're doing
and nobody can really come up with any
meaningful arguments against it. It
seems like people mostly agree but don't
want to put in the work that you do.
Probably on the right path.
>> You could say the things have to be this
way.
>> Something like this has to work.
Therefore, you got to keep going. That's
the top down. And it's based on this
like multifaceted beauty and inspiration
by the brain.
>> All right, we'll leave it there.
>> I'm fixing that with Puffer Ryan.
>> Thank you so much. Thank you so much.
>> All right. Appreciate it.
>> That was great.
>> Yeah, I'm Jod's.
>> Yeah, [laughter]
>> everybody. I hope you enjoyed that
episode. If you did, the most helpful
thing you can do is just share it with
other people who you think might enjoy.
>> Everybody watching, there you go. Leave
a rating or a comment on whatever
platform you're listening on. If you're
interested in sponsoring the podcast,
you can reach out at.com/advertise.
Otherwise, I'll see you on the next one.
Cool. So, for everybody watching, hello.
Um, at least some of you are new around
here. So, hi, I'm Joseph. I am a
reinforcement learning researcher.
um finished my PhD a couple years ago.
Now I run Puffer, which is a small
private RL lab. We do all open source
stuff. We train tiny superhuman models
in seconds. You can run them on your
laptop.
It's all right here. And I stream pretty
much all of my dev on the uh project as
well. So if any of this sounds
interesting to you and you'd like to see
more of this stuff,
first of all, Star of the Puffer on
GitHub helps me out a ton. try out the
code. We have all docs and demos here.
You can join the Discord to get involved
with development. Pretty much everybody
involved professionally with this stuff
just started by building some
environments, you know, starting to get
a feel for the field like this. And you
can also follow me on X, which is the
main spot that I post all of my stuff.
Uh I am currently working on Puffer 4,
which is targeting 10 million step per
second RL training. We're going to have
something that can really train on tens
of thousands of years worth of data on a
single server. Um, we have a new
architecture that we've come up with
with Puffer 4. We are doing some
low-level dev on optimized kernels. Um,
a lot of just transparency on how to
make this stuff actually as fast as it
needs to be.
And that's pretty much what I do in a
nutshell.
We hit like 40 concurrent pretty much
across platforms here. So funny that
that's how it goes as soon as I pull up
a VOD. But uh yeah, I'm going to go get
some dinner. I'll answer any quick
questions if anybody has them. Um
yeah, that is pretty much what I do. Oh
yeah, and then the other thing is if
you're looking to get into RL or learn
more, I do have a little bit of free
educational material here.
These two articles are the best place to
start. This is all of my best advice for
general engineering and how to view
science in a way that will help you
understand a lot more of what is out
there quickly. And then this is the uh
the same for reinforcement learning.
This is a pretty much step by step like
read this, build this, read this, build
this. And if you follow this, you will
learn RL. Way less math heavy than a lot
of the stuff out there. kind of a pretty
heavy blend of engineering with some
basic science thrown in, a little bit of
math. That's what I do.
Hey, Hyper.
You doing podcast review
thing?
Fireball. Yeah, the fireball one is kind
of like a funny thing. Um, I am sort of
serious about it in some sense that like
I basically just said, "Hey, you know,
all you guys are spending so much bloody
time like arguing over the definitions
of AGI and moving the goalpost every so
often. You know, in 2018 or whatever, I
just said screw it. You know, the
definition of AGI is when I can cast
fireball." So, when basically when AI
produces something that's essentially
magic, then we're good. Um,
Cuz otherwise, as you've seen, like the
name of the game is just move the damn
goalpost around and like say a bunch of
things that don't make any sense and
don't really matter. So, this was kind
of just like a screw it, get back to
real work, you know, build the awesome
stuff, stop debating whether you've
succeeded or not.
Again, a funny one. Back on streams for
more internet zero to hero. That's good.
XI claims about doing real time
video processing plus action model for
Grock 5. Uh if they try to do League
just by like running Grock on League,
it's going to be hilariously bad.
Uh if they actually spend a ton of
compute to train like that on League,
they might get something more sample
efficient than Dota. They're going to
spend a ton of money though for what is
ultimately a worse result than OpenAI 5.
Uh oh yeah. So this is I actually have
right behind me here. I'll show this.
I'll show So right behind me, you see I
have the servers above me right here.
And then if I turn this,
you can see that monitor. I just got
that. that actually has all of the
experiment data
for some of the 40 experiments.
And
honestly, the main thing with the new
update for Puffer, it's we're trying to
make RL about three times faster than
the previous version. We have a new
architecture that's going to be slightly
better. And then we're going to use all
this new speed to just run a massive,
massive number of experiments. And
there's a new visualizer for aggregating
all that data to hopefully get us some
really cool insights about RL.
That's the main thing
he's not bad, right? It's he kind of
just strikes me as like a kind of a
normal dude that doesn't have like a
deep math and science background trying
to understand this stuff and like talk
about it generally, right?
I think it was mostly the um the thing I
said before, right, where it's like,
yeah, maybe it's just he has a big
general audience and like some of his
viewers are just like, "Oh, this guy's
the AI genius." not like it's kind of
like um like Lex Freriedman or Joe Rogan
or what like you know how just they're
these big podcasters that mostly they're
just like dudes with a big audience and
they talk to like they get a bunch of
cool guests but then for whatever reason
some fraction of their viewers seem to
mistake and think like oh actually the
interviewer is the one who's a massive
genius and like what they say is the
word of God like it seems fine.
Micron exiting the consumer. I don't
know anything about that. How would you
train self-driving problem? It's our
biggest uh our biggest collab right now
with the university. This puffer drive
sim. This is being used by actual
self-driving companies.
Just a high performance sim.
You load in real map data to this thing.
The point of this is that you can just
like you get so so much data out of this
that like if you don't have a ton of
real world data but you have these maps
you can still train on a ton of
scenarios
RL on the fly without catastrophic
forgetting
not really the so I kind of have a
different perspective Fred I'm not
trying to hit the same target that
everybody else is with LLML
What I'm trying to do is instead of like
how do we make RL adapt, I'm just going
to make RL stupidly stupidly fast and
then make it very easy to have high
performance simulators for tasks that
you care about. You can just go train on
pabytes or more of data for your given
problem on one server
and see every possible permutation of
it. So like in some sense I don't have
to solve that problem for my approach to
work.
the big general models kind of have to
solve that problem because they can't
train on the amount of data that I do.
It's kind of funny like the main
objection I get to a lot of my work with
this is oh well it's good for games but
not much else and then it's like I take
the exact same exact same code exact
same everything. Ah cool it flies a
drone. Ah cool it drives a car and then
I throw it on problems for clients like
the main thing Puffer does
professionally is we build um high
performance sims for companies and ah
look it does uh compute market pricing.
Oh, look. It does this finance task,
right?
So, yeah, RL's really powerful and it's
going to be it's gotten like a thousandx
better in the last two years. And that's
not hype. That's not exaggeration. It's
actually gotten a thousandx better. And
we've got at least another order of
magnitude, probably two coming in the
next couple of years.
Jensen on Joe Rogan. That's hilarious.
What do you do about pedestrians?
Uh, yeah. So, you would want them in the
sim obviously.
Like, it's not like we're insta
deploying this. Like, this is a
relatively small sim for some relatively
smaller companies. There is a pedestrian
model. I believe some maps have them.
There's like a different pedestrian
model, but yeah, you would want
pedestrians.
And then you can have them like cross
randomly and have all sorts of different
events and not collide with them.
Initially though, what this thing is
really good for is like this thing gets
you you can basically train models that
never collide
or collide ridiculously infrequently.
Frankly, there are um there are bigger
maps as well that have much longer
horizon tasks in them. I think they're
working on the team for that is at NYU
and they're a couple of them are at
Nurups right now if anybody's there.
But yeah, this is evidently even in the
current state is already useful for um
driving sim companies, not driving sim
companies, for uh for self-driving
companies. So cool.
The plan for the next couple of days,
um I'm probably going to see if I can
fix the vectorzation stuff on stream
tomorrow. We've got this new uh
multi-threaded C back end for puffer and
I need to redesign this chunk of code a
little bit and this should get us tens
of millions of steps per second
vectorization to support the new
version. And then uh what other stuff is
there?
We've got custom kernel dev stuff to
work on. We've got some experiments, a
variety of different things for 40.
Oh yeah, if you're new, Star Puffer,
join Discord, follow on X. Those things
help. Um,
this is currently the fastest growing RL
library and I'd love to keep it that
way. It really does help me just spend
all my time on this project rather than
doing other stuff, [ __ ] advertising.
If you are interested in RL in a
professional setting, we have stuff
available for that. And that's about it.
So, thank you. And I'm going to go get